drei Spieltage hatte es gedauert. Am dritten Spieltag der Saison 2223 ging's schon wieder los. Und alles begann hier, im Dortmunder Westfalenstadion, bei der Partie zwischen dem BVB und Werder Bremen. Dortmund führte mit 2 zu Null, es lief bereits die 89. Minute. Doch dann passierte etwas, das es in der Geschichte der Männerbundesliga so noch nicht gegeben hatte. Stefan Henze kommentierte das Ganze für die Sportchef.
Nur noch 1 zu 2, mit dem linken Außenriss hat er den Ball in den rechten Winkel reingehämmert.
Tor für Werder!
Es ist Niklas Schmidt.
Mit dem Kopfball in die Nachspielzeit. Werder, Bremen gleich aus. Nochmal die Bremer mit dem Schweißer.
Ja, kommen wir letztlich dann auch wieder als auch eine Form der Gemeinwohleökonomie, da ist es dann nicht das Bepreisen des gesellschaftlichen Werts, sondern das Lenken der Geldströme, das man eben sicherstellt.
Genau.
Ein Teil davon fließt auch wieder zurück an die Gesellschaft. Die Gegenargumente, die können wir beide jetzt blind schon runter rattern, das werden immer dieselben sein. Wir können da nicht mehr die Champions League gewinnen und so weiter und so fort. Die Frage muss man sich aber halt vielleicht auch stellen, ob das dann wirklich immer so wichtig ist und ob – also da gibt es ganz viele Scheindebatten. Es war zum Beispiel ja noch nie so, dass die größten Stars in der Bundesliga gespielt haben. Also vielleicht Anfang der 80er als Paul Breitner, Karl-Heinz Rummenigge und Horst Rubisch waren, glaube ich, bei der Wahl zu Europas Fußballer des Jahres auf Platz 1, 2 und Rubisch dann irgendwie in den Top 5 noch. Also da war es vielleicht mal ganz kurz so, dass die besten Fußballer der Welt aber nicht mal die spektakulärsten in Deutschland gespielt haben.
Ja, ein Tod muss man wahrscheinlich sterben.
Aber lass noch ganz kurz zum Abschluss daherkommen, woher dieser Impuls kommen kann. Denn ich will jetzt auch keine Sendung machen, in der die Argumente alle so ausgehebelt werden der Diskussionen, die es gerade so gibt. Ich glaube, das ist leider notwendig, weil es sind sehr viele Scheindebatten gerade. Ich möchte, dass es nicht nur düster wird. Ich glaube auch, das was du gesagt hast mit den Ultras, da liegt glaube ich viel Wahres drin. Aber das ist letztlich auch eine Jugendkultur und wie ungerecht wäre es eigentlich von einer Jugendkultur zu erwarten, dass sie sich so gut organisiert, auch noch eine in sich ja eigentlich auch sich voneinander abgrenzende Jugendkultur. Also es sind ja nicht alles Punks, die gegen die Gesellschaft sind, sondern es sind quasi genauso die Schalke-Punks wie die Dortmund-Punks. Und die beiden wollen aber miteinander überhaupt nichts mit zu tun haben eigentlich. Also es ist ja noch komplizierter. Also von denen, das zu erwarten, ist es eben.
Wer weiß, ob es in zehn Jahren Ultras noch gibt. Also wenn wir auf die jungen Leute schauen, die können mit dieser Meine Stadt, mein Stadion, mein Blog und dieser Rhetorik können die schon auch immer weniger anfangen, würde ich behaupten. Aber das wäre natürlich auch eine Möglichkeit, dass man sagt Support your local football team. Also alle Fans, die ihr Geld jetzt in die PTV-Abos und in die Trikots von Manchester City stecken, könnten natürlich auch einfach den Verein vor der Tür unterstützen.
Ja, aber da ist ja der Fußball schlecht, da ist das Produkt schlechter. Also deswegen wird es sich nicht durchsetzen. Also die Frage, die ich mir stelle, ist, bräuchte man – also es muss einen Impuls geben und der Impuls kann nicht aus dem Fußball selbst herauskommen – bräuchten wir vielleicht die Kultur-Trass, also quasi die verkopften Menschen wie du und ich und wie noch Leute wahrscheinlich, die auch das jetzt hier hören, denen auch von ganz vielen anderen abgesprochen wird, dass sie irgendwie den Fußball verstanden hätten und so weiter, aber die quasi so oft und beharrlich auf die Missstände im Fußball hinweisen, dass eben dann irgendwann die Politik und andere Akteure doch mal ins Rollen kommen, so wie es ja schon im ganz kleinen auf EU-Ebene zum Beispiel ja schon geschehen ist. Kann daher vielleicht der Impuls kommen? Oder überhöre ich jetzt Leute wie dich und mich?
Ich fürchte schon. Also wir versuchen es ja schon seit einigen Jahren, würde ich behaupten, aber die Mehrzahl der Menschen, die sich mit Fußball beschäftigt, möchte schöne Dinge über Fußball lesen, möchte unterhalten werden und möchte einfach mal abschalten vom Alltag und möchte sich nicht auch noch in der Freizeit mit den Problemen des Fußballs beschäftigen, wenn er ist im normalen Leben, in der normalen Welt, schon Probleme. Es ist eine sehr desillusionierende und unromantische Antwort, aber ich fürchte, es ist die Wahrheit.
Das heißt, im im Kern des Fußballs, in dem was ihn besonders macht, nämlich dass er eine so herrliche Ablenkung ist und ein so tolles Spiel ist, liegt auch gleichzeitig die Keimzelle seines Untergangs.
Genau so ist es. Der Fußball ist quasi Opfer seines eigenen Erfolgs geworden, in dem er so groß geworden ist, dass er für so viele Menschen anschlussfähig geworden ist, die ihn nicht mehr komplett brennen für ihn und ihn möglichst gerecht und vielfältig und gewährs wollen, sondern die sich einfach nur berieseln lassen wollen. Das ist das Problem.
Dann muss man den Fußball neu denken. Dann habe ich jetzt noch eine abschließende Frage. Ich habe jetzt Angst vor der Antwort, ehrlich gesagt. Wie sieht der Fußball in zehn Jahren aus?
Ich glaube, wir haben in zehn Jahren die erwähnte Null zu DIGA, in der sich die reichsten Vereine des Kontinents tungeln werden. Das ist dann Circus und das ist dann der Tainment Pool. Die Spiele laufen alle live auf TikTok oder dem Nachfolge TikTok. Darunter haben wir aber eine Bundesliga, die näher dran an den Leuten ist, die nachhaltiger ist, die gerechter ist und die dem, womit wir aufgewachsen sind und wo wir Fußball-Romantiker wurden, näher ist als heute.
Die aber dann vielleicht auch nur noch wie ihr alten Säcke gucken.
Vielleicht. Aber mehr tatsächlich bei dem Gespräch für das Buch. Einer gesagt, naja, guckt mal in den USA, da gibt es im Football die NFL. Glitzer, Glitzer, mega kommerziell, erfolgreich, volles Stadion, toll, aber irgendwie doch, entrückt und das wissen aber alle. Und dann gibt es auf der anderen Ebene dieses Cottage-Football-System. Ich weiß, Edville Byrne und so ein bisschen kann man nicht komplett vergleichen, aber da gehen auch hunderttausend zu den Spielen der University of Alabama, I don't know, ja. Es ist alles ein bisschen regional, also alles ein bisschen mehr Identifikation. Der Sport ist auch nicht so gut, aber der begeistert trotzdem die Kinderreizenden noch. Vielleicht kommt es diesem Null-Züge-Bundesliga-Modell schon viel näher, als wir gerade denken.
Ich hoffe ehrlich gesagt nicht, denn der College-Football ist das Beispiel der größten Ausbeutung von Sportland durch ein kapitalistisches System.
Ich wusste, dass du immer wieder ein Gegenüber-Menschen hast.
Ja, es tut mir leid, aber es ist doch so.
Sie profitieren von diesen Milliarden, profitieren die Spieler am aller, aller wenigsten. Das ist tatsächlich Kapitalismus auf die Spitze.
Mir ging es jetzt auch gar nicht um die Bedingungen für die Spieler, sondern um das Feintum, wenn man so will, und um die Atmosphäre und das Luke-Hardering.
Tut mir leid, dass ich es dir kaputt gemacht habe. Aber du hast mir auch viel kaputt gemacht. Es war ein destruktives, aber doch irgendwie konstruktives Gespräch. Christian, herzlichen Dank dir für deine Zeit. Das war also mein Gespräch mit Christian Spiller. Was ich gelernt habe? Die Bundesliga-Vereine wollen nichts verändern, weil sie Angst um das haben, was der Status Quo ist. Die Verbände und Fans schaffen es aus unterschiedlichen Gründen nicht einzugreifen. Und dass ich ein Miesmacher bin, weil ich immer ein Gegenargument nenne. Am Ende des Gesprächs war ich ehrlich gesagt ernüchtert. Auch weil Christian mir ausgerechnet den Akteur klein geredet hat, in den ich persönlich gerade noch die größte Hoffnung setze, die Ultras. Sie sind doch die Einzigen, die beharrlich auf die Gier und Ungleichheit im Fußball hinweisen. Aber klar, die organisierten Fans sind nur eine Randgruppe. Da hat Christian schon recht. Aber kann eine Revolution nicht auch vom Rand aus starten? Höchste Zeit mit jemandem zu sprechen, der genau darüber ebenfalls nachgedacht hat. Ich schließe mich mit Raphael Meuter zusammen. Raphael hat das Buch Friede den Kurven, Krieg den Verbänden geschrieben, in dem er zunächst das System Fußball setziert und dann fast eine Art Gebrauchsanweisung dafür schreibt, wie die Ultras es zum Wanken bringen könnten. Einig ist er sich mit Christian in seiner Beschreibung der Problemlage. Die wirtschaftliche Ungleichheit im Fußball droht dem Fußball das zu nehmen, was ihn besonders macht.
Der Fußball ist kein Spiel mehr, das im Kapitalismus funktionieren muss. Es ist zu einem kapitalistischen Spiel geworden, in dem für eine Handvoll Vereine und Funktionäre die Variablen des Zufälligen ausgemerzt und Profite gesichert werden sollen. Ein Spiel, das keines mehr sein darf.
Was sieht also Raphael, wenn er auf den aktuellen Fußball blickt?
Ich sehe einen Fußball, der vorgibt, allen zu gehören und dann am Ende eben doch nur sehr wenigen wirklich gehört. Und ich habe im Buch auch immer mal wieder überlegt, wie kann man diesen Fußball eigentlich auch begrifflich fassen. Es gibt ja von Christian Bartlau diesen doch eher schwierigeren Begriff des marktkonformen Fußballs, der wahrscheinlich sehr gut beschreibt, was wir sehen. Nämlich ein Fußball, der eigentlich von diesen Idealen sich ableitet, dass am Anfang der Saison jeder die gleiche Chance hat, eine Liga oder ein Pokal zu gewinnen und wir dennoch ganz genau wissen, dass es nicht der Fall ist. Ich weiß nicht so ganz, ob dieser Begriff des marktkonformen Fußballs genau auch das beschreibt, was wir sehen. Ich glaube, dass es ein bisschen allgemeiner besser ist. Ich glaube, wir haben es mit dem kapitalistischen Fußball zu tun. Damit meine ich auch den herrschaftlichen Fußball, weil die Unfairness, die uns dieser Fußball Woche für Woche aufzeigt, kann man ja versuchen, in so einen Gesamtzusammenhang reinzupacken. Ich glaube, dann ist es auch ganz gut, wenn wir auch im Fußball und auch in der Fußballbetrachtung nicht mehr so einen riesengroßen Bogen um das umsagende Wort mit K machen.
Das ist in dem Fall nicht die Kanzlerfrage, sondern die Kapitalismusfrage. Wie siehst du denn die Situation im breiten Sportfußball? Sprichst du da jetzt nur über den Leistungsbereich des Fußballs oder was meinst du damit?
Grundsätzlich würde ich über den institutionalisierten Fußball sprechen wollen, weil das, was wir im Fußball erleben, das was auch alle immer beschreiben mit den Begriffen des Commerz und der Eventisierung, das ist ja zumindest in einer versuchten wissenschaftlichen Annäherung ja ganz simpel eine kapitalistische Landnahme. Das heißt, dass quasi ein kapitalistisches Sein immer versucht, neue Märkte zu erschließen. Und das sehen wir am Fußball ganz wunderbar. Und diese kapitalistische Landnahme konkurriert ganz eindeutig mit der Institutionalisierung des Fußballs. Und das ist dann, da können wir natürlich dann innerhalb dessen noch mehrere Wellen sehen. Aber wir haben es grundsätzlich seit knapp 100 Jahren mit einem institutionalisierten Fußball zu tun. Nichtsdestotrotz konzentriere ich mich ja vor allen Dingen in meinem Buch auf die Herrschaftsverhältnisse im Profifußball. Allerdings muss man halt eben auch ehrlicherweise sagen, dass diese klare Trennung von Profi versus Amateurfußball, glaube ich, so nicht mehr zu machen ist, weil ja auch in den vermeintlichen Amateurliegen mittlerweile mehr und mehr Geld ist und dann eben nicht nur Geld, sondern eben dieses Geld ist ja am Ende eben Kapital und da haben wir es dann eben interessanterweise auch zwar mit anderen Auswüchsen zu tun, ich glaube auch Auswüchse, die man genauer noch untersuchen müsste, aber ja das ist, ich glaube nicht, dass diese Unterscheidung so einfach zu machen wäre, aber sie ist natürlich einfacher, um herrschaftliche Grundlagen dieses Fußball zu analysieren, dann konzentriert man sich wahrscheinlich besser auf den Profifußball.
Der eine Bereich ist ja auch sichtbarer als der andere, aber das ist ja eigentlich interessant, dass wir im Amateurfußball mit den vielen Mezänen, die es da gibt, mit den Geldern, die da gezahlt werden, oft auch an der Steuer vorbei, wie jüngste Recherchen ja herausgefunden haben, dass wir da interessanterweise ähnliche Mechanismen der Kapitalakkumulation und des Konzentrierens von Macht letztlich auch, also die sich dann ausdrückt, in Zugang zu spielen, die man sich eben einkauft und so weiter, dass wir da ja fast schon eine Imitation des Leistungsbereichs haben, könnte das vielleicht ein Hinweis darauf sein, dass es nicht am Fußball liegt, sondern an dem System und der Gesellschaft, in die er eingebettet ist?
Wahrscheinlich, ja. Also ich würde es nicht anders begründen wollen. Denn wenn wir uns angucken, welche Symptome wir haben – du beschreibst es ja richtig – die Symptome sind im Ansatz sehr ähnlich und vor allen Dingen zeigen sie ähnliche bis fast schon gleiche Tendenzen auf, dann müssen wir uns angucken, was die Ursache dafür ist. Und dann landen wir wahrscheinlich bei Kapitalismus. Und um nicht einfach nur mit dem Wort umherzuschmeißen, Kapitalismus beschreibt natürlich nicht einfach nur eine Wirtschaftsordnung, sondern wenn man aus so einer eher das große ganze im Blick nehmen wollen, auch aus einer materialistischen Perspektive, die eben wirklich vom Sein und vom Ökonomischen ausgeht, dann sehen wir relativ gut, dass der Kapitalismus eben nicht einfach nur eine von verschiedenen möglichen Wirtschaftsordnungen ist, sondern dass diese Wirtschaftsordnung oder diese Sphäre eben grundlegend ist für unser gesamtes gesellschaftliches Zusammenleben und dass kapitalistische Verhältnisse uns offensichtlich in allen Lebensbereichen in seiner eigenen Logik reinzwängen.
Ich glaube, das bedarf noch ein bisschen einer Erklärung. Nicht jeder wird es Marx und Engels gelesen haben. Ich übrigens auch nicht. Immer nur in der Sekundärliteratur, wie ja auch in deinem Buch, da wird es ja auch immer wieder zitiert. Was sind denn diese kapitalistischen Zwänge, in die man da hereingezwungen wird?
Wenn wir uns mal angucken, nicht nur im Fußball, sondern auch ganz grundsätzlich in unserem Leben, dann dürfte, glaube ich, auffallen, dass so gut alles diesen Regeln oder Gesetzen des Marktes unterworfen ist. Man kann sich ja immer im Einzelfall wundern, was dann genau damit gemeint ist. Aber ganz grundsätzlich geht es ja darum, dass quasi alles rationalisiert und ökonomisiert ist. Es ist quasi schon natürlich geworden, dass wir über den Fußball reden, wo immer die Frage ist, wie kann man das mit Sponsoren zusammenbringen und wie kann man dies oder jenes finanzieren. Das sind alles Fragen, die am Ende eben ganz klar diesen Kern des Problems auch schon ankitzeln, nämlich genau, dass das mit kapitalistischen Verhältnissen gemeint ist, dass wir eine Ökonomisierung und Rationalisierung aller Lebensbereiche erleben, die eben nicht mehr diese Ideale von einem schönen Leben oder Fragen nach Mensch, wie könnte denn eigentlich so ein Gemeinwohl aussehen gehen, sondern sich tatsächlich ganz stupide danach richten, wie man mehr Kohle ranholen kann.
Ganz kurz würde ich da gerne noch bei dem Thema bleiben und dann kommen wir auch wieder, ich verspreche es, zurück auf den Fußball. Aber welche Rolle spielt denn dann der Individualismus? Denn du hast ja auch gerade einmal das Wort Gemeinwohl fallen lassen und gleichzeitig führt ja aber der Kapitalismus zumindest jetzt in den Ausprägungen, wie wir ihn jetzt erleben, zu einer Individualisierung. Jeder versucht erst mal das Beste für sich herauszuholen, was ja auch – also das möchte ich jetzt auch gar nicht moralisch verstehen – erstmal ist es ja völlig normal. Jeder muss erstmal seine Grundbedürfnisse decken und soll das ja auch sehr gerne.
Ich glaube, dass die Individualisierung, die wir so gefühlt seit drei Jahrzehnten irgendwie wahrnehmen und die so ganz häufig unter dem Begriff des Neoliberalismus zusammengefasst wird, eigentlich eine historische Wiederkehr dessen ist, was den Kapitalismus im Kern ausmacht. Man könnte sich ja jetzt auch ganz grob überlegen, was für Ideale scheint dieser Kapitalismus voranzubringen. Ganz offensichtlich ist es ja eben der Wettbewerb und diese Konkurrenz aller gegen aller, die eben auch dazu führt, dass dieser Individualismus immer wieder hervorgehoben wird und der Kapitalismus braucht das offensichtlich als so eine Art Absicherung. Denn wenn wir einfach nur eine Wirtschaftsordnung haben oder eine gewisse Struktur, nach der unser Leben, unsere Gesellschaft funktionieren muss, dann geht das gar nicht ohne, dass wir ja gewisse Ideen dafür bereitstellen, um das legitimieren zu können. Also wenn immer wieder neu diese Grundfrage verhandelt werden kann von, ist das eigentlich klug, wie wir gerade als Gesellschaft zusammenleben, dann könnte man ja aus einer herrschenden Perspektive sagen, dann haben wir ein Problem. Und genau dafür schafft man Ideen und aber auch Ideologien, um das ein bisschen abzusichern. Und da gehört der Individualismus an aller vorderster Front, weil er eben auf einer nicht materialistischen, sondern auf einer sehr ideologischen Ebene ganz wunderbar erklärt, warum der Kapitalismus super ist. Du kriegst ja irgendwie allen Leuten vermittelt so im Sinne von, ja, jeder muss ja erstmal auf sich achten und wir müssen hier irgendwie durchkommen. Und Gemeinwohl ist quasi dann etwas, was man sich leisten muss, sobald es dem Individuum besser geht. Das ist aber, glaube ich, nichts Besonderes, was wir in den letzten drei Jahrzehnten gesehen haben, sondern es ist im Kapitalismus inhärent und war davor wahrscheinlich nur deshalb nicht so sichtbar, weil politische Verhältnisse da eben auch anders waren und weil, ja, am Ende eben auch die Kämpfe stärker ausgetragen wurden.
Ja, und vielleicht auch die Not nicht so groß war. Also mit einer wachsenden Ungleichheit und das muss man jetzt nicht nur auf die aktuelle Zeit beziehen, sondern da kann man auch eine Geschichte weit zurückgehen. Je größer die Ungleichheit innerhalb einer Gesellschaft, desto mehr schwindet das Glücksempfinden nicht nur bei den Namen, sondern auch bei den Reichen und desto mehr werden solche Konflikte dann auch sichtbar. Ich will jetzt dann den Bogen zum Fußball schlagen. Ich habe deshalb jetzt nochmal nach dem Individuum gefragt, denn was in deinem Buch du viel machst, ist, dass du auch Abhängigkeitsverhältnisse aufdeckst sowie Doppelrollen, die verschiedene Akteure des Fußballs haben. Unter anderem die Ultras, zu denen würde ich gerne gleich kommen. Und da gehört das ja mit dazu, dass man, was sich quasi äußert im stupiden, ach die da oben in der Politik, die machen doch sowieso eine Politik für sich, das kann man halt leider nicht zu 100 Prozent verneinen und dem widersprechen, auch wenn man es gerne würde. Aber vielleicht in einem ganz kleinen Teil ist es eben so, dass eben auch jedes Individuum ja auch Absicherungsmechanismen für sich hat. Und wenn wir dann eben zum Beispiel über Fußballunternehmen sprechen, wo es Individuen gibt, die sehr gutes Geld mit ihrer Arbeit dort verdienen und sich quasi ihre Existenz darauf aufbauen, genauso wie auch bei Verbänden, wo das vielleicht sogar noch deutlicher zu sehen ist, dann glaube ich eben, dass es da eine Querverbindung gibt, eine Erklärung auch dafür, warum der Fußball sich so wie andere Bereiche der Gesellschaft auch in eine Sackgasse reingefahren hat und jetzt aber immer noch mehr Gas gibt, um noch mehr in diese Sackgasse reinzukommen, anstatt mal etwas daran zu ändern, weil eben es ganz viele Menschen gibt, die ein Interesse daran haben, persönlich und für ihre Institution, dass man dort verbleibt, wo man jetzt gerade ist und einfach die Spirale noch ein bisschen weiter dreht.
Ich glaube, am Ende ist es auch ein ganz wunderbares Beispiel dafür, dass es eben nicht so ist, dass man als Individuum dauerhaft gegen Strukturen sein, sie noch so schlecht oder noch so kaputt ankommen kann. Also, man kann das ja auch mal ganz praktisch erzählen. Wenn ich jetzt morgen nach Prager fliege, dann wird es davor auch intensive Auseinandersetzungen gegeben haben, ob es denn überhaupt sinnvoll wäre und ob es klug sei, mit dem Flieger darunter zu brettern für einen Tag, um dann wieder zurückzukommen. Und ich meine, da hat ja auch die Union der Twitterbubble auch eifrig überdiskutiert. Ich glaube, das ist eine völlig falsche Herangehensweise, weil sie eben tatsächlich auch philosophisch nicht ganz geklärt, auf was konzentrieren wir uns gerade eigentlich und was soll es überhaupt gehen. Geht es um das große Phänomen des Klimawandels, der Klimakatastrophe, dann muss man halt ehrlicherweise sagen, dass es komplett irrelevant ist, ob ich irgendwohin fliege oder nicht. Und sage es sechsmal im Jahr, weil es gibt halt eben nun mal deutlich andere, deutlich größere Faktoren. Ich finde es halt aber auf der anderen Seite auch wahnsinnig spannend, genau das immer wieder versuchen einzubetten und sich dann eben auch zu überlegen, nur weil ich sage, dass Strukturen quasi Grundgegebenheiten vorgeben. Oder ich glaube, Donata Hopfen – ich glaube, oh, war das Donata Hopfen? Ich bin mir nicht mehr ganz sicher – im Rahmen der Taskforce Zukunft Profifußball gab es mal vom DFB oder von der DFL eine Vertreterin, die kommuniziert hat, dass man nicht außerhalb der Autobahnleitplanken rausgehen kann. Und das ist eigentlich ein relativ gutes Beispiel dafür, was es am Ende bedeutet, in einer kapitalistischen Gesellschaft zu leben. Weil klar, du kannst die Spur wechseln, du kannst auch mal ein bisschen reformistischer werden, auch eben progressiver Druck machen, du kannst ja eben auch den neoliberalen Hardliner 200 kmh-Stil fahren, wie es Lindner macht, aber du wirst nicht außerhalb dieser Leitplanken rauskommen. Und das beschreibt relativ gut dieses Spannungsfeld aus einerseits die Analyse auf Strukturen und Herrschaftsverhältnisse ausrichten, um sich anzugucken, in welchen Sachzwängen wir uns tatsächlich befinden, wenn wir über gewisse Dinge reden, andererseits darf es nicht dazu verkommen, dass dann daraus abgeleitet wird, ja, es ist Determinismus, ja, hochhundert und egal, was du als Individuum machst, es ist eigentlich völlig egal. Und das ist ein wahnsinnig spannendes Spannungsfeld, in dem man sich da bewegt.
Okay, puh, sortieren wir das mal. Wie ihr hören konntet, sind Raphael und ich sofort richtig tief eingetaucht in Grundsatzfragen. Wir haben ja auch den Vorteil, dass wir beide sein Buch kennen. Raphael sieht, genau wie Christian Spiller, den Fußball als kapitalistisches System. Anders als Christian ist das für ihn aber der Ausgangspunkt der Analyse. Indem wir den Kapitalismus und seine Mechanismen verstehen, lernen wir auch etwas über den Fußball. Dazu gehört zum Beispiel eine Erkenntnis, die vor allem auf Karl Marx und Friedrich Enges zurückgeht und die Raphael früh im Buch erklärt.
Die beiden Theoretiker haben sich im 19. Jahrhundert mit einer philosophischen Grundausrichtung beschäftigt, die sich bei Marx auf einen Satz zusammengefasst wiederfindet. Es ist nicht das Bewusstsein der Menschen, dass ihr sein, sondern umgekehrt ihr gesellschaftliches Sein, das ihr Bewusstsein bestimmt. Der Kerngedanke lautet, die wirtschaftliche Struktur bildet die Basis einer Gesellschaft. Die wirtschaftlichen Gegebenheiten bewirken eine bestimmte Art von Politik oder auch eine bestimmte Art von Unterhaltung oder Sport. Unser wirtschaftliches Sein bestimmt unsere sozialen, politischen oder geistigen Prozesse. Auf eine Analyse des Fußballs übertragen, bedeutet das eine schonungslose Auseinandersetzung mit dem Fußball und seinen wirtschaftlichen Rahmenbedingungen. Denn Fußball existiert nicht im luftleeren Raum. Fußball hat eine gesellschaftliche Funktion, die losgelöst von der wirtschaftlichen Struktur nicht zu verstehen ist.
Und weil diese Struktur, wenn man Marx und Engels folgt, auch bestimmt, wie wir unser Leben gestalten, habe ich den Individualismus in unserer Gesellschaft zur Sprache gebracht. Überall wird suggeriert, dass es jede und jeder schaffen könne, sich wirtschaftlichen Erfolg zu erarbeiten. Dafür brauche es nur Leistung. Sowohl in unserer Gesellschaft als auch im Fußball ist das aber falsch. Nicht jeder hat die gleichen Startvoraussetzungen. Gleiche Leistung führt eben nicht zu gleichem Erfolg. Und doch brauchen wir den Glauben an dieses Prinzip. Denn sonst könnten wir nicht rechtfertigen, warum viele Dinge in unserer Welt so sind, wie sie sind. Im Fußball zum Beispiel? Ist wirklich die Mannschaft die beste Deutschlands, die mit hunderten Millionen Euro Einsatz die meisten Spiele gewinnt? Aber da stoßen wir eben schnell an das, was Raphael als Leitplanken des Kapitalismus bezeichnet hat. Gewisse Dinge gelten als unverrückbar. Und das muss auch so sein – zumindest aus Sicht derjenigen, die über den Fußball herrschen, wie Raphael aus der Entstehungsgeschichte des institutionalisierten Fußballs herleitet.
Vor 100 Jahren hatten wir in Deutschland noch kein Verbandsmonopol. Da hatten wir auf der einen Seite einen bürgerlichen Fußballverband mit dem DFB, auf der anderen Seite einen eher proletarisch ausgerichteten Arbeiter- und Turnsportverband. Und da sehen wir aber nichtsdestotrotz eine Tendenz, die bis heute anhält und die relativ gut erklärt, warum wir Herrschaftsverhältnisse im Fußball haben. Denn diese Herrschaftsverhältnisse sind erst dann reingekommen, als man den Fußball als gesellschaftliche Sphäre für sich entdeckt hat, aus Perspektive der Herrschenden. Ich meine, das ist ja auch keine neue Erkenntnis, dass Fußball ganz wunderbar sich für die Herrschaftsrepräsentation ereignet. Wir werden das jetzt in Katar erleben, wir haben es im Russland erlebt. Wir erleben es quasi Woche für Woche bei Red Bull Leipzig oder bei Paris Saint-Germain oder bei Newcastle oder bei Man City. Der Sprech von Brot und Spiele, die der Sport sein soll, das kommt ja eben auch alles nicht von ungefähr. Dahinter steckt natürlich eine befriedene Funktion, gesamtgesellschaftlich. Aber wir haben das jetzt eben auch erlebt und das erleben wir in den letzten zwei Jahrzehnten immer drastischer, dass es eben nicht einfach nur darum geht, dass Fußball so eine Art Ablenkungs-Sphäre für uns hart- und lohnabhängige Menschen ist, die Tag für Tag eben irgendwo scheffeln müssen, damit sie Miete bezahlen und Essen bezahlen können, sondern dass der Fußball sich selbst zu einem eigenen kapitalistischen Markt entwickelt hat und dort eben auch Geld verdienen wird oder wissenschaftlich korrekter, dann kapital akkumuliert wird. Und genau das ist, glaube ich, das Spannende, was wir dann betrachten müssen, was Herrschaftsverhältnisse angeht. Denn wir müssen verstehen, wie dieser Fußball ganz grundlegend funktioniert. Und dieser Fußball hat nicht einmal nur einen herrschaftlichen Charakter dahingehend, dass er uns befrieden soll, sondern stattdessen hat der Fußball noch weiterführende Funktionen erhalten. Und da dreht sich wirklich alles rund darum, dass da Kohle gemacht wird. Und ich meine, da reicht ja ein Blick in den DFL-Wirtschaftsreport von 2021. Da steht, glaube ich, drin, dass die DFL einen Umsatz von 5, 4 Milliarden Euro gemacht hat. So, das ist schon verdammt viel Geld. Und da sehen wir auch direkt daran, dass all das nicht ohne Herrschaftsverhältnisse aufrechterhalten werden kann. Und ich weiß nicht, ob ich dem Monolog hier einfach gleich weiterführen kann, aber Herrschaftsverhältnisse, da müssen wir auch direkt zum Thema Fans kommen.
Ja, warte, dann würde ich gerne noch eine kurze Rückfrage stellen und dann endlich zu den Fans kommen. Denn ist es denn verwerflich oder falsch, Geld zu verdienen? Erstmal ist das doch okay, wenn die DFL richtig viel Reibach macht. Sie bekommt es ja auch nicht von irgendwo, sondern letztlich kommt das Geld ja auch von den Fans, die das ja dann offensichtlich mittragen wollen. Also die Befriedung, die es aus dem Fußball gibt, die lassen sie sich sogar noch etwas kosten. Also es ist ja auch ein schöner Eskapismus.
Wenn wir in dem kapitalistischen Fußball eben leben oder nicht nur leben, sondern da eben auch als handelnde Akteure unterwegs sind, da müssen wir uns diesen Regeln ja unterwerfen. Und da kommen wir nicht drumrum. Und dass wir Geld nun mal als zentrales Tauschprinzip in unserer Welt haben, da wird der Fußball auch selbst nichts daran ausrichten können. Ich glaube auch, dass er selbst an dieser Orientierung immer mehr Geld zu machen, nichts ändern kann, weil das eben auch ein zentrales Gesetz dessen ist, wie dieser Fußball zu funktionieren hat. Und ich glaube auch nicht, dass selbst einzelne Verbände daraus ausbrechen könnten. Deshalb ist es eine ganz schwierige Frage zu behaupten, das sei moralisch verwerflich, weil das ist es am Ende nicht. Ich glaube bloß einfach, dass es in der Grundausrichtung ganz falsch ist und nicht funktionieren kann und offensichtlich den Fußball so korrumpiert, dass all das, was wir mit dem Fußball eigentlich verbinden, so nicht mehr sichtbar wird. Und ich habe da letzte Woche auch ein wahnsinnig spannendes Buch geschrieben von unter anderem Jonas Wollenhaupt zu Link's Kickbesser, und das beschreibt es ja auch relativ gut, dass Fußball eigentlich ideengeschichtlich ganz viele linke Ansätze und linke Ideale hervorbringt. Und all das sehen wir ja heutzutage nicht mehr. Das ist aber eben eine moralische Frage, bei der ich dann wiederum antworten würde, dass es schade, den Fußball so in seinem jetzigen Zustand zu sehen ist. Das halte ich für nicht richtig. Auf einer materialistischen oder auf einer strukturellen Ebene ist es – was soll ich dazu sagen? Natürlich muss der Fußball Geld verdienen und natürlich ist es gut zu sehen, wenn auch mein Lieblingsverein gut wirtschaften kann, weil ich dann weiß, dass sie – egal wie die Einzelnen zum kapitalistischen Fußball stehen – zumindest verstehen, wie man innerhalb dieses Konstrukts überlebt und trotzdem erfolgreichen Fußball spielen kann.
An dieser Stelle ist es glaube ich gut, noch mal kurz zu unterbrechen, um das zu unterstreichen, was Raphael gesagt hat. Es geht nicht darum, dass der Fußball kein Geld verdienen soll. Es geht darum, dass seine kapitalistische Struktur ihn zu dem gemacht hat, was er jetzt ist. Wenn man das kritisiert, muss man auch den Kapitalismus im Fußball kritisieren. Von Gegnern wird diese Kritik gerne auf eine moralische Ebene gehoben und lächerlich gemacht, à la die linken Socken erträumen sich ein sozialistisches Fußballsystem. Aber darum geht es gar nicht, wenn man die Funktionsweise des Fußballs so beschreibt, wie Raphael und ich. Zunächst ist es nicht mehr als das Aufdecken seiner Struktur und erst ausgehend von diesem Befund kann dann jeder sein eigenes Ideal vom Fußball entwickeln. Und klar, das kann dann auch moralisch hergeleitet werden. Man kann aber auch versuchen, es materialistischer und damit nüchterner zu betrachten. Ist vielleicht die Gleichung einfach nicht vollständig? Der Fußball verdient mit diesem Spiel Geld und gibt auch Teile der Gesellschaft zurück. Der Fußball als Spiel und als Sport kann ja sehr, sehr viele für viele gute Dinge stehen, also er kann Menschen zum Sport machen bringen im Breitensport. Er hat eine eskapistische Funktion. Auf der anderen Seite verwendet er aber auch Ressourcen, die dann fehlen und da muss man jetzt also natürlich gibt es da das Klimaargument, das betrifft alle Lebensbereiche. Gleichzeitig profitiert ja aber der Fußball auch von Ausbeutungs- und Herrschaftsmechanismen, die auch in anderen Bereichen kommen, also egal, ob es jetzt eben bei der Herstellung der Merchandise-Artikel ist. Bei den Kosten, die zum Beispiel entstehen für die Sicherheit rund ums Stadion und so weiter und so fort. Also man muss ja nicht sagen, der Fußball darf kein Geld verdienen, das sagst du ja auch nicht, aber vielleicht den Blick auf die andere Seite der Gleichung rechnen und häufiger die Frage stellen, was gibt der der Gesellschaft, dem Gemeinwohl zurück und ist das so noch in der Balance?
Das ist eine gute Frage. Ich würde vielleicht sogar noch einen Schritt weiter gehen und mir überlegen, was uns der Fußball denn insgesamt sagen kann, weil wenn du auch schon darüber ansprichst, dass wir ganz viele Problemfelder in diesem Fußball sehen, dann würde ich auch direkt schon mal das nächste Feld aufmachen im Sinne von als Kurzbeispiel anreißen, denn wir sehen ja bei der Weltmeisterschaft in Katar, dass da ganz viele Dinge zusammenkommen, die eigentlich auch so ganz grundsätzlich primär mit dem Fußball nichts zu tun haben, also das Phänomen der Arbeitsmigration, der Nachhaltigkeit, du sprichst es an. All das sind ja eigentlich Dinge, die so grundsätzlich mit dem Fußball nichts zu tun haben sollten und dann aber eben in der konkreten Ausgestaltung der Sphäre Fußball, wie wir sie heutzutage eben leben, dann eben doch sein müssen. Und ich glaube, dass bei all dem nicht die Frage darin besteht, wie man da an kleinen Drehschrauben was ändern kann, sondern dass der Blick da darüber hinausgehen muss. Und zwar in der Frage, wie wir all diese Symptome, die wir da sehen, dann irgendwie wieder zusammenbringen können. Denn klar kann der Fußball auch in seinen kapitalistischen Verhältnissen mehr zurückgeben. Und ich glaube, es ist nicht ausgemacht, dass selbst der Fußball in den jetzigen Verhältnissen so bleibt, wie er ist. Denn wir sehen einen Fußball, der weitestgehend unreguliert ist. Wir sehen einen Fußball, der zumindest in deutschen Verhältnissen eigentlich auf allen wichtigen Spitzenpositionen von SPD-Leuten besetzt ist, wo man auch eigentlich sagen müsste, das sportpolitische Programm der SPD liest sich recht progressiv. Da müsste eigentlich deutlich mehr drin sein. Es passiert bloß interessanterweise nichts. Und das ist dann eben genau die Frage, die man sich eben stellen muss. Nicht einfach bloß immer utopisch zu gucken, was wäre alles möglich und was könnte man machen, sondern sich konkret an den Herrschaftsverhältnissen zu orientieren, um die Frage zu stellen, warum passiert das nicht, was jetzt schon möglich ist. Wir müssen das erst verstehen, was wir bekämpfen wollen, oder wir müssen noch einfacher und nicht so böse formuliert, wir müssen erst mal verstehen, wie der Fußball funktioniert.
Da haben wir jetzt schon viel darüber gesprochen, aber wir haben ein Thema um Schifft, was eine ganz wichtige Rolle in deinem Buch spielt, nämlich die Rolle der Fans und der organisierten Fans der Ultras. Warum sind sie, also die Ultras, als Akteure im Fußball deiner Meinung nach so wichtig?
Das mag vielleicht ganz interessant klingen, weil – und ich glaube, das wissen die allermeisten – zumindest Ultragruppierungen in Deutschland verstehen sich nicht per se politisch. Und es gibt eher linke politische Ausnahmen an Ultragruppierungen. Ich würde da jetzt zum Beispiel an die Schickeria von Bayern München denken, Ultra St. Pauli, auch die Szenen in Freiburg bei Babelsberg 03. Das sind alles eher linke Fanszenen. Ganz grundsätzlich sind die deutschen Fanszenen aber ja eher gar nicht so. Auch auf dem Schirm, die haben das auch nicht so klar auf dem Schirm im Sinne von wir müssen den kapitalistischen Fußball bekämpfen und all das. Und ich glaube, das ist auch gar nicht das, was sie so wertvoll macht. Es ist mehr ihre Praxis. Denn dauerhaft zu sagen, dass man links gegenherrschaftlich, demokratisch, antikapitalistisch ist, das macht einen nicht dazu. Also es bedroht auch erstmal nicht die Verhältnisse, die man ändern möchte. Sondern es ist die Praxis, wie wir Dinge leben, wie wir Dinge organisieren, die das dann herausfordert und Nischen für eine bessere Welt, einen besseren Fußball, eine bessere Gesellschaft aufzeigt. Und so widersprüchlich es klingt, Ultras sind wahrscheinlich der Schlüssel für einen anderen Fußball, weil sie genau das in ihrer Praxis aufzeigen. Sie sind größtenteils basisdemokratisch organisiert. Sie sind in dem Sinne gegenher schafftlich, als dass sie wirklich autonome Räume sich suchen, wo der Staat, aber auch die Fußballinstitutionen, die Verbände wenig Einfluss darauf nehmen können, was da passiert. Und sie sind – das wird ja auch immer wieder zitiert – die größte Jugendkultur, die wir in Deutschland haben. Und sie ist dementsprechend auch eine Subkultur, die all das herausfordert, für das eben unser bürgerlicher Staat und der kapitalistische Fußball stehen. Und das macht es tatsächlich so spannend, sich mit ihnen zu beschäftigen. Nicht weil sie selber sagen, dass sie der Schlüssel zu einer besseren Welt sind, sondern weil sie es tatsächlich in Ansätzen schon leben und das tatsächlich ein Vorbild sein kann für die Heterogenität der vielen Fußballfans, wo man ja am Ende sagen muss, wenn wir einen anderen, wenn wir einen besseren Fußball haben wollen, dann funktioniert das nicht über politische Kämpfe und dann funktioniert das nicht, ohne sich zusammenzuschließen. Und dann muss man eben was suchen, worauf man sich einigen kann. Und ich glaube, dass die Ultras, die Organisation der Ultras, da viele Vorteile bietet und viel dessen aufzeigt, wie man es besser machen kann.
Ich bin wirklich keiner, der Ultras verteufeln möchte, ganz im Gegenteil. Aber wenn du sagst, die Ultras sind eben basisdemokratisch und das alles, was du gerade besprochen hast, dem könnte ich jetzt entgegenhalten. Und wie gesagt, ich will das jetzt nicht pauschalisieren, aber ich glaube, jeder dieser einzelnen Punkte ist richtig in Teilen und du sprichst auch einige davon an. Ultras sind nicht nur basisdemokratisch, Ultras sind manchmal auch extrem hierarchie-durchsetzt, Ultras sind manchmal misogyn, Ultras sind manchmal rassistisch, Ultras sind manchmal antisemitisch. Auch das gehört zu Ultras mit dazu. Ultras sind manchmal gewaltbereit.
Ja, das ist ja eben genau diese Widersprüchlichkeit des reellen Lebens, in dem wir uns wiederfinden müssen. Wir werden keine Strukturen finden, die perfekt sind. Und ich glaube, die Ultrakultur, wie auch Ultrastrukturen, sind weit, weit, weit davon entfernt. Also, man kann es ja ganz simpel einfach zusammenbringen. Wir haben da einerseits diese unbewussten Abgrenzungsstrategien, die teilweise auch sehr bewusst sind. Ich kann immer ein ganz kurzes Beispiel geben. Ich habe eine gute Freundin, die, wenn sie nicht das falsche Geschlecht hätte oder einfach eine nichtmännliche Person wäre, ganz sicherlich in einer Ultragruppierung wäre. Und das passiert einfach nur deshalb nicht, weil eben das, was die Hansa-Rostock-Subtraß so widerlich sagen, dieses Weiber aus den ersten drei Reihen, das gilt ehrlicherweise ganz grundsätzlich für ganz viele Fanszenen in Deutschland. Wir haben ganz wenige Beispiele von Ultragruppen, die tatsächlich auch nichtmännliche Personen zulassen. Und da geht es ja dann eben erst los. Du hast es alles angesprochen, es ist alles vollkommen richtig. Es ist bloß immer die Frage, es ist eine Frage der Ausrichtung. Möchte ich jetzt für meine Utopie so lange warten, bis ich irgendwann Organisationen, organisationelle Ansätze sehe, im Sinne von da kann ich hingehen? Oder gucke ich nicht einfach, was man mit dem machen kann, was schon da ist? Und natürlich brauche ich sehr arg viel Kritik. Aber das Gefühl, was ich auch momentan habe, ist, dass Ultras da eher zuhören, als es eben doch andere Gruppen tun. Das hat eben auch viel damit zu tun, dass sie sich eben als gegenherrschaftlich begreifen und dass sie eben ein gewisses Grundgefühl eben teilen, dass mit dem kapitalistischen Fußball so nicht viel stimmt. Und ja, das ist keine Ausrede dafür, dass diese Widersprüchlichkeit da ist. Aber am Ende muss man eben damit umgehen. Man muss damit arbeiten, was man am Ende hat. Und sich nicht einfach darauf zurückziehen, dass, weiß ich nicht, der FC Heidenheim eine Super-Ultra-Gruppierung hat und die erste Flinter-Ultra-Gruppe hat. Und super, dann machen wir nur was mit denen. Mit denen wird aber keine Fußballrevolution zu machen sein. Das sind dann halt einfach 20 Personen, sind zu wenig.
Ja, also und du sprichst ja schon von Revolution. Also es geht um einen Systemumsturz. Ich glaube, dieses Wort kommt sogar direkt so vor, auch in deinem Buch. Gleichzeitig haben wir ja aber vorhin schon darüber gesprochen, die berühmten Leitplanken, die du vorhin zitiert hast, dass es sehr schwierig ist, bis fast unmöglich aus bestehenden Verhältnissen heraus ein System umzustürzen. Eigentlich bräuchte es eine extern einwirkende Kraft. Aber auch die Ultras haben ja eine Doppelrolle, die sie auch anerkennen müssen als allererster Schritt, bevor man überhaupt erstmal losmarschiert Richtung, tja, Frankfurt DfB. Ich weiß es nicht, wohin man dann marschieren würde, um jetzt die Revolution anzuzetteln. Kannst du mal diese Doppelrolle beschreiben und wie fängst du das quasi auf in deinem Wunsch, dass aus den Kurven heraus eine Veränderung im Fußball angestoßen werden könnte?
Bei Ultras und bei Fußballfans generell – ich würde Fußballfans mal so aus einer systemischen Analyse einfach mal als einen Akteur beschreiben wollen – ist es relativ simpel, dass sie nicht einfach bloß in dieser Konsummaschinerie gefangen sind, wie es ja, weiß ich nicht, zum Beispiel auch im Theater oder bei einem Kinobesuch der Fall ist, sondern dass sie auch ganz aktiv für die Stimmung mit sorgen. Also ich meine, wenn man ins Kino geht, dann wird man schwerlich den Eindruck bekommen, dass ich hier gerade diesen Kino-Filmen mitprägen kann und diese Stimmung und den Ausgang bestimmen kann. Das geht alles nicht. Im Fußball geht das. Und das zeigt eben auch ganz wunderbar, dass, obwohl dieser kapitalistische Fußball ja sich eher dieser Unterhaltungsindustrie unterordnet, es da eben doch einen ganz großen Unterschied gibt. Wir als Konsumentinnen sind eben nicht einfach nur Konsumentinnen im Fußball, sondern Fußballfans sind eben an der Produktion, an diesem Produkt Fußball direkt mitbeteiligt. Und auch das hat die DFL mal dankbarerweise für mich sehr klar ausgedrückt. Ich war vor zweieinhalb Jahren mal im Ausland, im Malaysia, musste da irgendwie das Nachts-Fußball immer gucken. Und da ist ja tatsächlich dieser internationale ausländische Slogan für die Bundesliga von der DFL, ist Fußball wie er sein sollte. Und dann sind da nur Bilder von Choreos, von Fans, die Pyro halten und von irgendwelchen Konfettis, die rumfliegen. Und da sieht man dann schon relativ eindeutig, dass es nicht nur für die Fans darum geht, dass es quasi notwendig ist, sie als Absatzmarkt zu begreifen und dass wir kaufen, kaufen, kaufen müssen, dass wir irgendwelche Abonnements abschließen müssen bis zum geht nicht mehr, dass wir uns im optimalen Fall ein Trikot kaufen wollen für 100 Euro, wenn die Saison losgeht, dass wir immer und immer wieder, wenn wir in unser Stadion wollen, ein Ticket bezahlen müssen mit mindestens 15 meist mehr Euro, um überhaupt drinne zu sein. Und dass dann die Stimmung, die wir reinbringen, aber auch noch ökonomisch verwertet wird. Und das ist am Ende eine Doppelrolle, in der Fans gefangen sind, in der es eben nicht so einfach ist zu sagen, ah ja, wenn wir das alles nur boykottieren, dann wird der Fußball so, wie er es zusammenbrechen. Das ist eben nur die eine Seite der Medaille. Die andere Seite ist ja auch, dass wir Fußballfans trotzdem ins Stadion gehen wollen. In dem Punkt, also in dem Schritt, dass wir ins Stadion gehen, indem wir Stimmungen machen, indem wir ja quasi dafür sorgen, dass ein emotionaler Unterton dazugefügt wird. In dem Moment sorgen wir eben auch für diese Profitabilität des Produkts Profi-Fußball.
Jetzt gibt es hier aber auch ein Mengenverhältnis, das auseinander rollt. Also du schreibst selbst in deinem Buch, ich zitiere, Sie sind in einer Doppelrolle gefangen, also die Fans, die es ihnen nicht ermöglicht, Teil des Spiels zu sein. Nehmen sie am Fußball teil, unterstützen sie seine kommerzielle Entwicklung. Sie sind unwidersprochener Teil des kapitalistischen Fußballs. Die fortlaufende Entwicklung und Veränderung des Spiels sorgt ebenfalls für einen Wandel der Fans. Die Wichtigkeit der Fans in den Stadien dieser Welt nimmt ab. An ihre Stelle rücken Fans, die kaum ortsgebunden sind und sich einfach nur unterhalten sehen möchten. Untergräbt das nicht schon ganz viel von deinem Ansatz, dass das ja eine korrekte Beschreibung ist, meiner Meinung nach, dass die Stadionfans zwar noch für Bilder gebraucht werden, die könnte man aber vermutlich auch irgendwie anders generieren, diese Bilder durch Kameraeinstellung von Schüssen in Nahaufnahme und Zeitlupe und was weiß ich auch immer. Also irgendwie wirst du Dramatik immer erzeugen können auf einer bildlichen Ebene. Aber die eigentlich entscheidenden Fans für den Fußball, die sitzen eben gar nicht mehr Stadion, die sitzen vom Fernseher und oft auch gar nicht mehr in Deutschland. Wenn wir gucken, wo die DFL zum Beispiel noch Geld verdienen möchte, es wird ja zunehmend schwerer, dass sie noch mehr Geld generieren kann, dann geht es ganz oft um die Auslandsvermarktung.
Ja, und das ist auch ein ganz wichtiger Kritikpunkt. Jetzt ist nun aber eben genau das Problem, dass zwar dieser wachsende Auslandsmarkt sehr, sehr wichtig ist, um neues Kapital zu akkumulieren, ist aber ganz offensichtlich keine wirklichen Fans sind, die man mit diesem Fußball längerfristig an sich binden kann, sondern es ist sehr, sehr volontil, wie viele und ob überhaupt Leute zugucken. Das heißt, du kriegst keine wirkliche Bindung hin und da fühle ich mich hier fast schon wie ein Marketingmanager, das zu sagen. Aber man muss halt wirklich sagen, dass die Millionen, die pro Saison in die Stadien pilgern, das ist die kritische Masse, die grundsätzlich immer als Absatzmarkt da ist. Mit denen wird man Geld verdienen können. Weil für die steht man nicht in Konkurrenz mit der neuesten Folge Big Bang Theory oder einem Super Bowl oder anderen Ereignissen innerhalb der Unterhaltungsindustrie. In der Auslandsvermarktung ist aber eben genau das der Fall. Man ist gezwungen, sich einer größeren Konkurrenz zu wehrzusetzen und natürlich wird es dann schwieriger mit einem Fußball, der aus genau dieser Problemlage heraus immer unattraktiver wird und eben auch dafür sorgt, dass er die Kapitalzentralisierung im Fußball auf immer weniger Vereine zunimmt, wie wir also dadurch einen Fußball haben, wo er von Anfang an Klarhas-Wer gewinnt, dass wir dann genau dieses Problem, was das System selber auslöst, dann auch wieder in der Rückkopplung sehen können. Dass nämlich diese Auslandsvermarktung eigentlich super wichtig ist, man sich selber da aber schon wieder am Bein stellt und man dadurch ja am Ende nicht auf die Fans im Stadion verzichten kann, weil das die Fans sind, die am Ende übrig bleiben, egal was passiert. Und das ist nichtsdestotrotz eine schwierige Frage zu überlegen, weil ich stimme dir vollkommen zu. Es ist ja ganz offensichtlich, dass die Fans in den Stadien immer weniger wichtig werden. Ich glaube aber auch, dass die Pandemie nicht nur uns allen, die ja irgendwie auch eine gewisse romantisierende Darstellung von Fußball im Kopf haben, so komme was wolle, wir sind damit groß geworden. Wir sind alle ins Fußballstadion gegangen, als wir noch Kinder oder Jugendliche waren, haben da irgendwo auch unser Herz verloren. Dass es nicht nur unsere Wahrnehmung ist, dass während der Pandemie ganz offensichtlich was gefehlt hat, sondern dass wir das ja auch innerhalb dieser funktionierenden Strukturen des Fußballs gesehen haben. Also auch in der DFL, auch in den DFB-Gremien, in Rumort ist ja. Und wir sehen auch ganz offensichtlich, dass es keine Ersatz ist, einfach lange Kameraeinstellungen von Slow-Mo-Aktionen zu zeigen oder, weiß ich nicht, 20.000 Pappaufsteller von vermeintlich wirklichen Fans aufzustellen. Das reicht nicht. Und ich glaube, dass vor allen Dingen die Bundesliga auch zeigt, dass es immer noch einen arg großen Einfluss nehmen kann, wenn Fans im Stadion vor Ort sind. Und ich meine, der Europa League Sieg von Eintracht Frankfurt ist ja die große populäre Erzählung im Sinne von, die Fans im Stadion haben noch nicht verloren.
Ach ja, wie oft der Europapokalsieg der SGE jetzt als Beispiel heranhalten darf oder muss. Zeigt vielleicht auch, wie sehr sich viele danach gesehen haben, dass mal wieder ein Underdog den großen Erfolg feiert. Aber schon interessant, wie hier die Meinungen meiner Gäste auseinandergehen. Christian Spiller stellt die Frage, ob es die Ultras in zehn Jahren überhaupt noch gibt. Raphael Malter hofft auf die organisierten Fanszenen als die Ecke, aus der ein Impuls kommt, der das System Fußball neu aufstellt. Und das, obwohl er den Ultras nicht unkritisch gegenübersteht. Jetzt gibt es ja auch schon viele kritische Aktionen innerhalb der Ultras, zum Teil auch miteinander verbrüdert. Das verschwestert, muss man ja leider weglassen, bei Ultras. Also zum Teil hat man da auch schon die Abgrenzungen untereinander ja aufgegeben, wenn man zum Beispiel sieht, dass zum Beispiel BVB und Bayern-Fans mit fast identischen Plakaten sich gegen die Champions-League-Reform ausgesprochen haben, gegen Ticketpreise und so weiter und so fort. Du wirst aber ziemlich früh in deinem Buch den Ultras und vielen anderen Akteuren auch im Fußball vor, in ihrer Kritik an der Oberfläche zu bleiben letztlich. Kannst du uns nochmal erklären, wie meinst du das?
Wir sehen hier eine Art Aktivismus im vorpolitischen Raum, der sich quasi den Symptomen nähert und gegen die Symptome protestiert. Und ich meine, RB Leipzig ist immer das perfekte Beispiel für sowas. Alle können sich irgendwie auf diesen einen gemeinsamen Nenner einigen. Es zeugt aber eben übrigens auch davon, dass wir da auch innerhalb dieser auch heterogenen Ultrakultur halt wirklich offensichtlich keine guten Willensbildungsprozesse haben oder dass da überhaupt die Möglichkeit für Diskussionen und für längere inhaltliche Auseinandersetzungen nicht gegeben ist. Weil stattdessen muss man halt irgendwie versuchen, möglichst viele unter einen Hut zu bringen. Und das sorgt eben dafür, was wir in den letzten zehn Jahren gesehen haben. Aktivismus über Analyse, RB Leipzig über Kapitalismus-Kritik. Das ist es ja am Ende. Und das ist ein Riesenproblem, weil es am Ende eben genau dafür sorgt, was wir momentan auch feststellen, dass diese Kritik in so einem diffusen Raum einfach stehen bleibt und man zwar irgendwie gegen die da oben wettert, aber auch nicht klar genau, um sich dann eben auch gegen rechte Strömungen abgrenzen zu können. Also wenn ich immer nur gegen RB Leipzig bin und Commerz an sich einfach doof finde und das aber eben auch nur mit diesem Wording begleite, keine tiefergehende Analyse dafür habe und auch keine Erklärung, warum es überhaupt zu so einem Produkt wie RB Leipzig gekommen ist, dann mache ich mich natürlich auch anschlussfähig für restaurative und faschistische Kräfte, die ja im Fußball auch beileibe immer noch nicht draußen sind. Und diese diffuse Kritik an all dem, die sorgt dann am Ende eben nicht für eine Verbesserung der Lage, sondern kann am Ende tatsächlich sogar auch dafür führen, dass die Art und Weise, wie momentan Fußball funktioniert, nur gestärkt wird, wenn eben kritische Kräfte sich dann eben aufgrund fehlender Analyse darauf einlassen, mit Leuten zusammenzuarbeiten, wo man ehrlicherweise sagen muss, mit denen ist kein besserer Fußball, mit denen ist keine bessere Gesellschaft zu machen. Und das ist ein großes Problem.
Gerade an der Kritik an Rasenballsport Leipzig hat man das sehr deutlich sehen können, wo es eben auch eindeutige antisemitische Tendenzen gab, zum Teil auch aus Fan-Gruppierungen heraus, von denen man das nicht erwartet hätte. Vielleicht auch manchmal wieder besseren Wissens in Unkenntnis. Wir haben das damals im Tribünengespräch zu Rasenballsport Leipzig auch mitthematisiert. Das ist definitiv oder war zumindest sehr lange ein Teil der Kritik an Leipzig. Da müssen wir jetzt nicht noch tiefer reingehen, außer du möchtest was sagen.
Also ich glaube zu den antisemitischen Auswüchsen, das ist ja lang und breit und ausführlich diskutiert worden. Ich halte das auch für sehr wichtig, das zu reflektieren. Es zeigt aber eben auch ganz grundsätzlich ein Problem auf, was man ganz wunderbar hätte umgehen können. Also natürlich, ich meine bei Red Bull, wo fangen wir da mit dem Problem an? Das ist ein proto-faschistischer Eigentümer, da an der Spitze der antidemokratische Tendenzen mit sehr sehr viel Kohle unterstützt. Und da geht es ja erst los. Also ich glaube grundsätzlich auch nur im Zusammenhang mit diesem Unternehmen genannt zu werden, würde mir persönlich auf moralischer Ebene ganz viele Probleme bereiten. Gott sei Dank bin ich kein Spieler oder Funktionär in diesem Konstrukt. Das viel grundlegendere Problem ist aber halt natürlich, anstelle sich auf Leipzig zu schmeißen, wäre es natürlich deutlich sinnvoller gewesen, sich damit auseinanderzusetzen, wie die Kommerzialisierung eigentlich im Fußball angekommen ist. Und dann würde man andere Antworten finden als Red Bull Leipzig. Und das ist es dann eben.
Genau, und dann lass doch jetzt mal darauf noch konzentrieren. Wir haben jetzt die Ultras als Akteure ein bisschen definiert und auch ihre Doppelrolle. Du hast ein paar Forderungen an Ultras. Du sagst, sie sollen ihre Abgrenzung verwerfen und Ausgrenzung beenden, also Abgrenzung untereinander, Ausgrenzung die marginalisierten Gruppen, die nicht stattfinden. In Ultras im Großen und Ganzen zumindest, mit einigen wenigen Ausnahmen. Das Konzept, das wir gegen die hinterfragen und untereinander verwerfen, ihre inhaltliche Unschärfe auflösen. Da kommen wir zu ganz vielen Dingen, wie jetzt nicht nur Kritik an Rasenballspurt Leipzig, sondern auch 50 plus 1, Salary Cap, Financial Fair Play, Aldi. Also eigentlich ein ganz gutes Beispiel ist das, was ich vorhin kurz angesprochen habe. Bayern-Fans und Dortmund-Fans waren sich darin einig, Stop-UCL-Reforms zu plakatieren in den Stadien, also sich gegen die Champions League-Reform auszusprechen. Und wenn man aber sagen würde, okay, gut, wir lassen die Reform, dann bliebe man ja bei einem System, was nur ein Mühe besser ist. Und das, finde ich, ist für mich das perfekte Beispiel. Und das sagst du ja in deinem Buch noch viel, viel wortgewandter und erklärst es besser. Aber wie sind denn jetzt dann mögliche Schritte zu einem Systemumschwung oder zu einer Verbesserung der Situation? Was würdest du dir wünschen?
Es geht darum, wie wir verhältnisse demokratisch und an sich am Ende eben gemeinwohl orientierter und besser organisieren können, in denen wir alle partizipieren können. Natürlich ist es aber eben ein großes Problem bei der aktivistischen Ausrichtung, die wir momentan erleben. Also klar ist es super wichtig, dass 50 plus 1 sich erhält. Natürlich ist es super wichtig, dass diese Grundform unserer Vereine als eingetragene Vereine eben auch gestärkt wird, weil sie so grunddemokratische Rechte eben erhalten. Aber wir sehen ja darin einen absolut rückwärtsgewandten Kampf. Also es fühlt sich ja so an, als wenn wir als Fans gegen die Mauer gedrückt werden und die Verbandsfunktionärinnen und Sponsoren und Unternehmen, die da irgendwie mit dem Fußball viel Kohle verdienen wollen, haben halt gefühlt zehn Messer in der Hand. Aber wir haben nur zwei Hände, um das abzuwehren und müssen uns irgendwie darauf konzentrieren, wie diese Abwehrkämpfe koordinieren. Wir sehen momentan, dass es sich sehr viel um die Erhaltung von 50 plus 1 und die Durchsetzung dessen, dass da keine Ausnahmen mehr davon von dieser Regel dann zulässig sind, dass es darum geht. Ich glaube aber, dass man aus diesem, ja, tatsächlich eben rückwärtsgewandten Kampf rauskommen muss, weil ansonsten eben auch dieser utopische Horizont gar nicht greifbar ist, den zum Beispiel Alina Schwerma ganz toll aufmacht, indem wir all diese Möglichkeiten sehen, wie wir sogar mit radikal- reformistischen Überlegungen schon den Fußball wirklich deutlich besser, demokratischer und ja, an sich am Ende auch einfach anschaulicher gestalten können. Aber das Ganze funktioniert eben nicht, indem wir immer wieder aus diesem 50 plus 1 kämpfen, irgendwie uns dann dem widmen, sondern wir müssen eine eigene Perspektive entwickeln. Und ich glaube, dass diese eigene Perspektive für Fußballfans nicht darin liegt, dass man irgendwie ganz klar aufzeichnet, so muss der Fußball in 20 Jahren aussehen, wenn wir alles überwunden haben und so kann es toll sein, sondern ich glaube, es geht viel einfacher darum, überhaupt mal die Möglichkeit aufzuzeigen, dass wir es schaffen können. Und ich glaube, dass auch hier der Blick sich über den Tellerrand ganz wunderbar lohnt, denn klar, ich bin Berliner, ich habe es dann auch relativ vom nahen heraus erlebt, aber die Volksinitiative Deutsche Wohnen und Co. enteignen, die hat eben eine ganz breite Mehrheit in der Stadtgesellschaft gefunden, selbst eben in Bezirken, wo man sich eher dachte, dass die da überhaupt darüber reden wollen, da nicht rausgejagt werden, ist schon überraschend. Und das zeigt eben die Notwendigkeit auf, für bessere Verhältnisse einzustehen. Und ich glaube auch nicht, dass der Fußball da eine Sphäre ist, bei der wir drumherum gehen sollten. Und für Ultras bedeutet das eigentlich noch viel mehr, nämlich, dass all das, was sie ganz grundsätzlich fordern, ja in der Mehrheit ganz offensichtlich auch genauso gewollt ist. Und die Frage sich viel mehr stellen muss, nicht welche coolen utopischen Ideen wir noch alles haben, sondern wie wir eben einen Weg dahin zeichnen können. Und ich glaube, dieser Weg ist keiner, der sich durch ja mangelnde Heterogenität auszeichnet im Sinne von, wir müssen jetzt alle gleiche Fußballfans sein, wir müssen gleiche Dinge verurteilen und wir müssen alle Dinge vergessen, sondern ich glaube, es geht viel mehr darum, sich dessen bewusst zu werden, was die Ideale sind, wo wir eigentlich hinwollen. Und das funktioniert am Ende dann eben nur dadurch, indem wir eine, ja, eine Fußballfan-Bewegung haben. Und ich glaube, das hört sich ein bisschen absurd an, dieses so, ja, wir müssen eine Fußballfan-Bewegung kreieren. Das wirkt irgendwie wie so ein dummer, theorieinteressierter Dude, der sich zuhause Gedanken macht und dann sagt, das und das muss gemacht werden. Aber wir sehen es ja eben schon. Wir sehen, dass Ultragopierungen sich sowieso bei gewissen Themen, insbesondere wenn es um Repressionen geht, sowieso automatisch untereinander solidarisieren. Wir haben das bei der Causa Dietmar Hopp erlebt. Wir erleben das jetzt auch im Falle von Qatar, dass es immer wieder Themen gibt und auch Themenkomplexe, die automatisch dazu führen, dass so ein kollektives Bewusstsein da ist. Ich glaube bloß, dass das ausgeweitet werden muss und dass sich das nicht nur bei 30.000, 40.000 Ultras in Deutschland irgendwie einstellen muss, sondern dass es auch um einen Kampf um das Stadion geht und zwar nicht um das Stadion als Eigentum, sondern um das Stadion als Versammlungsort, als Raum für demokratische Prozesse, in denen wir quasi die verschiedensten Fußballfans dafür gewinnen, was wir am Ende eben haben wollen, nämlich einen Fußball, der am Ende wirklich allen gehört und der es tatsächlich auch einfacher macht, all diese schönen Ideen, die eben vorhanden sind, auch dann tatsächlich mal umzusetzen.
Hier müssen wir mal kurz einen Exkurs machen, damit wir alle auf dem gleichen Stand sind. Rafael spricht über die Bürgerinitiative Deutsche Wohnen und Co. enteignen als Vorbild für konstruktiven Aktivismus auch im Fußball. Vielleicht habt ihr rund um die Bundestagswahl 2021 von dieser Initiative gehört, denn am selben Tag, an dem in ganz Deutschland Parlament und Regierung neu gewählt wurden, haben die Berlinerinnen und Berliner auch über diese Initiative abgestimmt. Die Deutsche Wohnen und Co. enteignen ist eine Reaktion der Berliner Zivilgesellschaft auf vor allem zwei Entwicklungen. Zum einen werden die Mieten immer höher und zum anderen gibt es einige große Akteure, denen immer mehr Immobilien in Berlin gehören. Von den rund 1, 5 Millionen Mietwohnungen in Berlin sind über 110.000 allein im Besitz der Wohnungsgesellschaft Deutsche Wohnen. Die Deutsche Wohnen ist an der Börse notiert, macht einen Milliardenumsatz und entsprechend agiert ein solches Unternehmen. Ich sag's mal so, das Wort Rendite könnte hierbei eine federführende Rolle spielen. Über mehrere Jahre hinweg haben verschiedene Interessengruppen deshalb einen Volksentscheid vorbereitet, der ein klares Ziel verfolgt. Unternehmen, die mehr als 3000 Wohnungen in Berlin besitzen, sollen enteignet und unter Marktwert dafür entschädigt werden. Fast 250.000 Mietwohnungen will die Initiative damit in eine Anstalt öffentlichen Rechts überführen, die transparent, demokratisch und sozial gegenüber ihren Mieterinnen und Mietern auftreten soll. Klingt ziemlich krass, wäre aber durch das Grundgesetz gedeckt, das in Artikel 15 genau so eine Vergesellschaftung von Privateigentum erlaubt. Der Volksentscheid wurde im September 2021 mit 59, 1 Prozent der abgegebenen Stimmen angenommen, bisher ist aber noch nicht so viel passiert. Aktuell berät eine Kommission darüber, was jetzt getan werden soll. Der angedachten Revolution ist also bisher nur ein laues Lüftchen gefolgt, noch wissen wir nicht, ob der Mietmarkt in Berlin sozial verträglicher gestaltet werden kann. Aber dass die Initiative Erfolg hatte, war ein deutliches Signal, dass bei guter Vorbereitung auch solche Ziele eine Mehrheit finden, die auf den ersten Blick utopisch wirken. Und noch mehr, sagt Raphael.
Diese Volksinitiative zeigt auf, wie Mobilisierung funktioniert, vor allem im 21. Jahrhundert, wie man mit linken und progressiven Inhalten ganz offensichtlich in gesellschaftliche Mehrheiten für sich gewinnt. Und ich glaube auch nicht, dass das irgendwie mit der besseren Überzeugung von Argumenten kommen muss, sondern indem man Leuten zuhört, indem man eben offensichtlich macht, dass kapitalistische Verhältnisse im Großteil von uns eben nichts bringt. Ich glaube aber eben auch, dass diese Volksinitiative ganz wunderbar aufzeigt, wo sie scheitert. Denn materiell gesehen hat sie nichts geändert. Also ehrlicherweise wirklich nicht viel. Sie hat den Diskurs beeinflusst. Und ich meine, das ist ja auch eine schöne Sache, dass vor der Bundestagswahl auch mal FDP, AfD und CDU, CSU dazu gezwungen wurden, sich irgendwie mit der Wohnfrage auseinanderzusetzen und dann eben auch erwartbar peinliche Antworten darauf geben, weil es aus ihrer Sicht nicht keine andere Möglichkeit gibt. Aber wir sehen ja auch gerade in Berlin, wie es eben ganz wunderbar funktioniert, selbst ein verfassungsrechtlich mögliches Instrument so zu verschleppen, dass am Ende daraus keine politische, keine gesellschaftliche Konsequenzen herauskommt. Also wir haben jetzt in Berlin eine Wohnungskommission, die paritätisch nicht nur von Expertinnen, der von Deutsche Wohnungen kur enteignen ist, sondern da kommen Expertinnen aus allen politischen Richtungen und man hat schon das eindeutige Gefühl, hier geht es wirklich nur darum, es einfach zu verschleppen, um am Ende nicht reagieren zu müssen. Und ich glaube, das ist genau das Problem, was wir bei der Volksinitiative sehen, was im Fußball nicht passieren darf. Mein Buch hat ja nicht ohne Grund im zweiten Untertitel diese Herrschaftskritik drin. Und ich glaube, das ist ein ganz wesentlicher Punkt. Der fehlt ja nicht nur Fußballfans, der fehlt ja auch linken Gruppierungen und auch linken Parteien ganz grundsätzlich, dass wir uns nicht immer nur damit beschäftigen müssen, was politisch in der Theorie möglich wäre, sondern wie die konkreten Herrschaftsverhältnisse aussehen, gegen die man das dann durchsetzen muss. Und erst durch das Verstehen und die Reflektion der gegenwärtigen Herrschaftsverhältnisse wird dann, glaube ich, deutlich, wie man darauf reagieren muss. Und dass es eben nicht einfach nur reicht zu hoffen, dass diese eine Artikel im Grundgesetz ja eigentlich die Vergesellschaftung ermöglichen sollte und dann einfach so lange drauf hofft, bis es dann halt irgendwann offensichtlich doch nicht funktioniert und man sich fragt, wie konnte es eigentlich dazu führen, dass man sie hier mit so einem billigen Kompromiss abgespeist wird. Und ich glaube, dass wir diese Entwicklung im Fußball ja sowieso schon seit mehreren Jahren sehen. Und da ist ja zum Beispiel die Task Force Zukunft Profifußball ein ganz wunderbares Beispiel dafür, dass da eigentlich ja auch wirklich ganz wesentliche reformistische Ideen reinkamen und ja auch eigentlich, so hört man es ja zumindest von den FanvertreterInnen in dieser Task Force, ja auch eigentlich da abgesprochen wurde, dass man in das Abschlusspapier auch zum Beispiel die Forderungen von Salary Caps reinschreibt, dass man eben vieles von dem umsetzt, was so einen progressiven Charakter hat, wo man weiß oder das naheliegende Gefühl hat, man kann den kapitalistischen Fußball hier ein bisschen eingrenzen. Man sorgt ein bisschen für die Eindämmung seiner Symptome und dass selbst das nicht funktioniert, macht ja sehr deutlich, dass wir uns auch im Fußball mit diesen Herrschaftsverhältnissen ganz dringend auseinandersetzen müssen und eben auch vor allen Dingen verstehen müssen, wie sich dieser kapitalistische Fußball eben absichert durch seine Verbände. Und erst wenn man versteht, wie das funktioniert und was die grundsätzlichen Tendenzen sind, glaube ich, dass man auch vernünftige Wege sich suchen kann, um dagegen vorzugehen. Weil wenn man immer nur in dieser diffusen mal reden wir mit den Verbänden und mal reden wir wieder nicht Situation bleibt, dann wird man am Ende keine grundlegenden politischen oder fanpolitischen Erfolge feiern können. Dann wird selbst das nicht möglich sein. Und das zeigt diese Taskforce ja momentan ganz wunderbar auf.
Deswegen eben Friede den Kurven, Krieg den Verbänden. Jetzt ist das natürlich ein historisches Zitat. Du willst nicht wirklich den Krieg erklären. Da gab es auch schlechte Erfahrungen mit, wenn man dem DFB den Krieg erklärt. Das kommt in der breiten Öffentlichkeit, wird das nicht so ganz verstanden. Was dahinter stehen könnte vielleicht noch. Aber was wären denn jetzt dann konkrete Zwischenschritte, die passieren könnten, Schreckstrich müssten aus deiner Sicht heraus, damit sich etwas im Fußball verbessert?
Es braucht so einen Entzündungspunkt. Es braucht einfach einen Moment, wo sich eine kritische Masse aufregt darüber, was da eigentlich passiert, und sagt, ja, so geht es halt echt nicht. Ich glaube aber, da kann es nicht aufhören, weil klar, wir haben immer mal wieder Momente, auch in den letzten Jahren, wo sich eine kritische Mehrheit irgendwie gefunden hat und gesagt hat, ey, so wie es ist, das kann nicht laufen. Und ich erinnere gerne an die Proteste 1212, als da das Sicherheitspapier 2012 eingeführt werden sollte. Und dann die ersten zwölf Minuten und zwölf Sekunden ja wirklich in allen Stadien Ruhe war. Und es dann nicht nur Ultras gab, die das boykottiert haben, sondern ganze Stadien, die einfach gesagt haben, ey, wir werden hier die ersten zwölf Minuten und zwölf Sekunden keine Stimmung machen, so. Sowas sehen wir immer wieder. Ich glaube, dann ist es deutlich wichtiger, einerseits aufzuzeigen, wohin es gehen kann. Es braucht so gefühlte Etappenziele, dass man die Leute auch bei Stange hält. Was so blöd wie es ist, wenn ich jetzt irgendwie aus dem Boden meiner eigenen Organisation stampfe, die dann irgendwie heißt, überwinden wir den Fußball in seiner jetzigen Form, dann werde ich wahrscheinlich am Ende 20 Jahre damit zubringen, in der Hoffnung, dass dann irgendwann alles so kommt. Aber da wird kein anderer Mensch mit mir diesen Weg gehen wollen. Oder maximal ein paar kleine. Es ist wichtig, auch im Fußball aufzuzeigen, dass dieses bessere Leben, dieser bessere Fußball, gar nicht so weit entfernt ist. Und dass man das tatsächlich ganz praktisch umsetzen kann. Ich halte nichts davon, immer wieder moralisch mal darauf zu kloppen und dann irgendwie mit Leuten da nicht zusammenzuarbeiten, weil da irgendwie was nicht passt. Und das kommt ja, glaube ich, bei den Ultras ganz gut zutage. Wir müssen mit dem arbeiten, was wir haben. Und ich glaube, dass es da deutlich wesentlicher ist, eine Ausrichtung zu schaffen, die einen Weg aufzeigt, wie wir Dinge bessern können. Und das bedeutet ganz grundsätzlich auch einfach mal, dass man zum Beispiel seinen eigenen Verein zurückgewinnen kann. Und das ist jetzt so das Abschlussthema, wo man auch sieht, wohin die Richtung geht. Wenn man diese Herrschaftskritik und auch diese Analyse der Verhältnisse, in denen wir leben, zusammennimmt, dann wird es tatsächlich sehr schwierig, eine Protestform zu finden, die nicht in irgendeiner Art und Weise entweder kapital- oder herrschaftskonform ist. Weil wir mit der ein oder anderen Sache immer wieder den Leuten in die Karten spielen. Wenn wir eine große Reformbewegung machen, um 50 plus 1 zu erhalten und Fanrechte zu stärken, dann muss man bei so einer Reformbewegung wahrscheinlich auch immer wieder mit den Fußballverbänden reden. Das würde ja mit meiner Analyse nicht konform sein. Das würde nicht funktionieren. Und ich glaube, das ist dieser revolutionäre Ansatzpunkt, der vielleicht auch ganz spannend ist und nochmal einen ganz anderen Horizont erweitert. Ich skizziere ja am dritten Kapitel nicht nur die Überlegung von einer kurven- und stadienübergreifenden Fanbewegung, sondern es geht ja auch ganz grundsätzlich darum, wie man den Fußballredemokratisieren kann. Und das ist das, was ich ja auch schon nie die ganze Zeit gesagt habe. Es geht mir nicht um irgendwelche Individuen oder um irgendwelche individuellen Handlungen, sondern mir geht es um Strukturen, die besser werden müssen. Weil wir auch in vermeintlich eingetragenen Vereinen sehen, wie zum Beispiel auch mein Verein Union Berlin ist, dass auch da demokratische Mitbestimmung aber wirklich aufs absolute Minimum reduziert ist. Also ich kann ja nicht mal bei unserer Mitgliederversammlung eine Satzungsänderung irgendwie einbringen, ohne dass sie von einem Satzungsausschuss, den ich demokratisch nicht kontrollieren kann, überprüft wird und dieser Ausschuss kann sagen, ja nö, lassen wir nicht zu. Und dann wird darüber nicht diskutiert bei der Mitgliederversammlung. Das ist ein Riesenproblem. Und ich glaube, das ist das, wo wir ansetzen müssen, weil die ganzen Fußballfans, egal welcher Couleur, egal ob Ultranormalo, Kutte oder Hool diskutieren sowieso. Wir diskutieren alle, wie es um unseren Verein steht, wie wir besser Fußball spielen sollten, aber wie es auch drumherum aussieht, wie es mit dem Fan-House vorangeht, ob es nicht irgendwie, weiss ich nicht, anderes Bier geben sollte beim Stadionbesuch. Und all diese Dinge müssen ja nicht in diesen Strukturen bleiben, die keine sind, indem man sich einfach irgendwo trifft und darüber spricht, sondern man kann diesen Prozessen und diesen Diskussionen ja auch einfach Macht geben, indem man sie zu einem Teil demokratischer Willensbildungsprozesse erklärt oder noch einfacher sagt, wir organisieren unsere Fußballvereine anders, indem wir eben sagen, wir bauen Fanräte auf, wir sorgen für eine ganz andere Form demokratischer Teilhabe, nämlich eine, die nicht über dieses Prinzip der Repräsentation funktioniert, indem wir irgendwelche Leute wählen, die dann ein oder zwei Jahre machen dürfen, was sie wollen, sondern indem wir uns tatsächlich selber treffen und die Leute, die wir dann wählen, in diesen Strukturen, die dann Machtposition übernehmen, dass die auch direkt daran gekettet sind, was wir wollen. Also wenn zum Beispiel – ich nehme jetzt mal das Beispiel des Präsidenten von Nürnberg von Dirk Zingler – wenn jetzt eine kritische Masse ohne Nürnberg-Fans das Problem mit Dirk Zingler hätte, dann wäre es nicht so einfach, ihn wegzubekommen, weil die jetzigen Strukturen eben kaum demokratische Teilhabe ermöglichen. Die Organisation im Fernrieten würde es aber natürlich relativ einfach machen, indem man dann einfach sagt, du hast ein imperatives Mandat. Das heißt, du kannst nur das machen, was wir dir sagen, was du machen sollst, und dadurch so eine direktdemokratische Rückkopplung haben. Und das wäre quasi genau das, wie man Fußballvereine schon redemokratisieren kann und in der Praxis aufzeigen kann, wie es anders organisiert werden könnte. Und ich glaube, aus den geänderten Strukturen kann dann eben auch was Besseres entstehen, nicht andersrum.
Die Räte Republik – jetzt auch im Fußball. So eine Initiative wie die Deutsche Wohnen und Ko enteignen, zeigt uns also, wie Mobilisierung funktioniert. Wir sehen aber auch, wo ihre Grenzen liegen. Wenn sich die Herrschaftsverhältnisse nicht ändern, dann wird sich auch der Fußball nicht verändern. Ich verstehe das alles, aber ob wirklich eine Redemokratisierung das löst? Vielleicht bin ich dazu pessimistisch, aber Fans können sich doch nicht mal darauf einigen, welches Essen im Stadion es geben soll, vom heißen Eisen der Biersorte, das Rafael angesprochen hat, mal ganz zu schweigen. Kann das echt funktionieren? Und vor allem, wie soll so etwas den Fußball verändern? Denn als Fan von egal wem – 1. FC Union, 1. FC Nürnberg, Werder Bremen oder Leverkusen – will ich doch zuallererst eines, dass es meinem Verein gut geht und der Erfolg hat. Erst dann kommen alle anderen Fragen und damit auch die Interessen anderer Vereine. Denn das ist ja nicht nur logisch, sondern auch schon bewiesen. Das sehen wir doch daran, wie sich die Vereine selbst Tag ein, Tag aus verhalten. Man kann sich ja die Frage stellen, warum haben die kleinen Vereine, die wirtschaftlich kleinen Vereine, denn eigentlich kein Interesse daran, mit klareren Regularien ihre Situation verbessern. Und die Antwort ist relativ einfach und das wird auch relativ offen inzwischen gesagt, weil sie Angst um ihre eigene Stellung haben. Also wenn quasi ihr direktes Konkurrenzumfeld alles stärker wird, weil man eben zum Beispiel Geld umverteilt, dann fühlt das ja gar nicht dazu. Also jetzt zum Beispiel eine Umverteilung der TV-Gelder würde ja gar nicht dazu führen, dass Bayern nicht mehr Meister wird, sondern die obere Mitte würde enger zusammenrücken und unten würde man enger zusammenrücken. Das heißt, es gibt die Angst, das zu verlieren, was man jetzt schon hat. Und diese Angst ist ja vielleicht sogar noch stärker in Fans immanent. Also wovor habe ich die allermeiste Angst, dass es meinen Verein A nicht mehr gibt? Okay, das ist eine große Angst, die ist aber sehr abstrakt und die wird meistens erst so kurz vor Insolvenzen aktiviert und dann ist auch Unglaubliches möglich, haben wir auch schon gesehen im deutschen Fußball. Und die zweite Angst ist, dass mein Verein keinen Erfolg hat, dass er absteigt, dass er in der Bedeutungslosigkeit verschwindet, dass er marginalisiert wird, vielleicht von einem anderen Verein, der an ihm vorbeizieht, vielleicht sogar im schlimmsten Fall noch einer aus der ähnlichen Region, das möchte man gar nicht haben. Ist das nicht das größte Problem, dass Fußballfans, egal wie radikal sie vermeintlich sind, dann doch eigentlich sehr anachronistisch sind und sich am liebsten einen bisschen besseren Zustand des Jetzt wünschen, indem aber bitte alles so ist wie in den 90ern, wo wir es alle so toll fanden angeblich?
Ja, ich glaube, das ist genau das ganz große Problem, was du beschreibst. Es gab einen großen Versuch, den mal zu entkommen, nämlich als eine große Gruppe an HS-POW Ultras sich von ihrem Verein losgelöst haben, als die Profi-Abteilung ausgegliedert wurde. Da haben sie ja gesagt, sie gründen ihren eigenen Verein, den HFC Falke. Da kann man jetzt nachgucken, wie man möchte. Der HFC Falke spielt gerade nicht im Profibereich und das macht relativ eindeutig, dass wir da eine Problemlage haben, aus der man sich nicht einfach ausmanövrieren kann. Und ich glaube, das zeigt auch die Komplexität unserer heutigen Welt auf, denn all die Probleme, die wir im Fußball sehen, können wir nicht innerhalb der Sphäre Fußball alleine lösen. Und das ist ein riesen, riesen Problem, denn einerseits versuche ich ja auch gerade, dauerhaft Wege zu finden, wie man quasi innerhalb dieser Sphäre Fußball Verhältnisse besser machen kann, indem man diese Zwangsverhältnisse irgendwie bekämpfen kann, durch eine bessere Praxis, durch theoretische Reflexionen und all das. Andererseits ist es ja eben auch ganz offensichtlich, dass all das nicht funktioniert ohne eine bessere Gesellschaft oder ohne eine Gesellschaft, in der auch um ähnliche Dinge gekämpft wird. Und ich glaube, diese Komplexität muss man am Ende damit zusammenbringen, dass man deutlich macht, dass ein besserer Fußball möglich ist, aber eben nur auch in einer besseren Gesellschaft und dass diese Kämpfe nicht voneinander getrennt werden können. Und ich hatte dazu auch mal vor ein paar Monaten in der linken Monat Zeitschrift Analyse und Kritiken relativ großen Artikel geschrieben, wo es dann quasi auch genau darum geht, dass Linke mal aufhören sollen, Fußball immer als so, ja, damit wollen wir uns nicht beschäftigen abzutun, sondern die Kämpfe sind sehr, sehr ähnlich. Und die Strukturen, in denen diese Kämpfe geführt werden, sie sind auch sehr, sehr ähnlich. Denn linke, ich meine, Antifa-Gruppen werden es kennen. Repressionen durch den Staat sind sehr hoch. Aber wenn es eine Gruppe gibt in Deutschland, die genau diese Repressionen auch kennt, dann sind das Ultras. Und man muss ganz offensichtlich machen, dass die Lösung für einen besseren Fußball eben nicht nur im Fußball selbst liegt, sondern dass man da eben auch darüber hinausgehen muss. Ich glaube aber, dass das ehrlicherweise kein allzu weiter Weg ist, weil auch hier, ich kenne es nur von den eigenen Ultragruppierungen von Union, aber auch hier meine Ultras bei Union, die sind nicht gerade dafür bekannt, politisch besonders aktiv zu sein oder mitlichen Gesprächen um sich zu schmeißen. Und dennoch solidarisiert man sich immer mal wieder eben auch mit Gruppen, die eigentlich so im Fußball, beim Kontext Fußball nicht auftauchen. So während der Pandemie gab es viele Spruchbänder in dem Kiez, die überall aufgehangen wurden, wo man sich bei den Leuten bedankt hat, die eben im Pflegebereich oder in den Krankenhäusern gearbeitet haben. Und ich glaube, das sind alles schon so Ansätze, wo man dann vielleicht dahin kommt, wo man dann eben genau eine Lösung für dein Problem findet, indem es nämlich darum geht, Kämpfe zu verbinden. Ich glaube, auch das haben wir schon im Ansatz dieses und letztes Jahr gesehen, als es zum Beispiel in Nordrhein-Westfalen darum ging, da ein neues Polizeigesetz eben zu verhindern, als dann eben ganz selbstverständlich auch Ultrakopierungen mit auf die Straße gegangen sind. Und ich glaube, hier sehen wir schon Tendenzen, bei denen es sich lohnt, dran zu bleiben und den Fokus deutlicher und klarer darauf zu legen, um aufzuzeigen, die Probleme im Fußball sind die Probleme unserer Gesellschaft und wir müssen Kämpfe aus den verschiedensten gesellschaftlichen Sphären zusammenführen, um eben diese Sphären besser zu machen, aber dann eben auch praktisch unsere gesamte Gesellschaft.
Und das erklärt eben auch, warum der Fokus so auf linken Strömungen liegt, weil der konservative Teil der Gesellschaft möchte ja eher, dass es bleibt, wie es ist. Und wenn wir aber in der Problemanalyse beim Ergebnis herauskommen, dass wir sagen, es muss sich etwas verändern, dann erklärt sich auch, warum du jetzt zum Beispiel eben gerade die Linken zitiert hast. Und das ist ja auch tatsächlich eine interessante Gemengelage, zumindest im deutschen Fußball, wenn man sich die Ultraszenen mal nur unter diesem Aspekt anguckt, wie viel linke Positionen werden da vertreten, wie viele davon definieren sich auch als links und wie viele davon tun das noch überhaupt nicht, obwohl sie eigentlich immer wieder linke Forderungen stellen und sich dessen aber vielleicht gar nicht bewusst sind oder vielleicht nicht weitergehen wollen und deswegen dann die linke Forderung nach eben Erhalt von 50 plus 1. Wenn das geschafft ist, dann verbrennt man das Plakat oder zerreißt es oder entsorgt es vielleicht auch regelrecht und dann ist man zufrieden. Das wäre ja dann kein linker Ansatz. Dann hätte man ja das bestehende System nur erhalten und nicht verändert. Zum Abschluss habe ich – ich bin eingestiegen mit einer allgemeinen Frage. Ich gehe raus mit einer allgemeinen Frage an dich. Raphael, was glaubst du? Wie sieht der Fußball in zehn Jahren aus?
Ich würde dir zwei Antworten geben. Ich würde dir eine realistische zuerst geben. In der realistischen dürfen wir davon ausgehen, dass wir bis dahin mittlerweile eine europäische Super League haben. Ich würde auch stark davon ausgehen, dass die Rolle der Verbände als quasi so Klebstoff des kapitalistischen Fußballs, dass diese Rolle ein bisschen abgeschwächt wurde, was aber nicht heißt, dass Herrschaftsverhältnisse aufgehoben sind. Ich glaube, wir erleben momentan eine neue Welle an Privatisierung im Fußball. Da würde ich sagen, sowohl im Profibereich als auch im Amateurbereich. Im Amateurbereich nehme ich das momentan auch arg wahr, dass man sich gar nicht mehr über den DFB in Fußballvereinen organisiert und da dann in der Liga gegeneinander spielt, sondern dass man das häufiger über Apps macht von irgendwelchen Start-ups, die glauben, es ist doch eine super coole Idee, selber den Fußball zu organisieren. Und ich glaube, dass das tatsächlich auch ein insgesamter Trend für den Fußball ist. Ganz grundsätzlich ist es halt aber am Ende eben auch eine Frage von, wer gewinnt die Kämpfe, die jetzt auszuführen sind. Wenn wir mal praktisch oder realistisch davon ausgehen, dass wir die Kämpfe als progressive Fans auf voller Linie verlieren werden, dann werden wir einen Fußball haben, der noch viel weniger mit unserem Fußball zu tun hat. Wir werden ein virtuelles Stadion-Erlebnis haben, was sich gerade anbahnt. Wir werden eine wahrscheinlich geschlossene europäische Super League haben, in der dann aber so Werkzeuge wie ein Salary Cap dann auf einmal verfügbar sind. So eine Art NBA für Fußball. Wenn du mich fragst, was ich am liebste für einen Fußball in zehn Jahren hätte, dann muss ich ehrlicherweise gestehen, einen Fußball, in dem kapitalistische Verhältnisse überwunden sind. Einen Fußball, der demokratisiert wurde. Einen Fußball, der wirklich allen gehört, und zwar auch strukturell, in dem die Vereine quasi das sind, was sie sein sollen, nämlich quasi das, wo ich mich als Fan zugehörig finde. Und wie das dann aber insgesamt aussieht, ist eine ganz spannende Frage, weil ich glaube, und das ist jetzt auch so eine Frage, ich habe ein ganz großes Problem mit den Verbänden, und ich glaube, das muss auch in den Fokus der Analyse. Aber wie sieht es dann aus, oder wie kann man Fußball ohne Verbände organisieren? Das kennen wir seit 100 Jahren eigentlich gar nicht mehr. Und ich glaube, das ist gar nicht so einfach, darauf eine Antwort zu finden im Sinne von, ich weiß, wie die Welt danach aussieht. Ich glaube aber, was die Grundideale sein sollten für diese Welt danach, und das bedeutet eben Redemokratisierung und dann tatsächlich echte Chancengleichheit für alle. Und dann lassen wir uns mal überraschen, wie schön der Fußball dann sein wird.
Ich weiß nicht, wie es euch geht, aber mich hat dieses Gespräch mit Raphael richtig gefordert. Ohne einen Crashkurs in Kapitalismuskritik war es schwer mitzukommen und gleichzeitig war es richtig wohltuend, mal anders über den Fußball zu sprechen als sonst, auch wenn man vielleicht zu einem ähnlichen Ergebnis kommt, nämlich dass sich wahrscheinlich wenig bis gar nichts ändern wird. Aber sein Grundgedanke ist meiner Meinung nach komplett richtig. Der Kapitalismus hat als System unsere Welt und damit auch den Fußball geformt. Womit nicht nur seine Funktionsweise gemeint ist, also die Ausrichtung auf Wachstum und Geld, Geld, Geld, sondern auch das, was Raphael Herrschaftsverhältnisse nennt. Die Struktur mit Verbänden, Vereinen und Funktionären ist vielleicht nicht vom Beginn an auf den Fußball als Geschäft ausgerichtet gewesen, aber sie hat sich dieser Denkweise angepasst. Wer sich zum Beispiel die FIFA rund um den Zweiten Weltkrieg anschaut, da wird die heutigen Zustände kaum wiedererkennen. Der damalige Generalsekretär Schricka musste den Fußball-Weltverband nicht nur durch die Zeit des europäischen Faschismus navigieren, sondern ihn vor allem am Leben halten. Von ihm ist Korrespondenz überliefert, in der er die FIFA-Verbände fast anbettelt um ihre Abgaben an den Verband. Heute ist die FIFA DAS Beispiel für maßlose Gier im Fußball. Nicht nur der Verband, sondern auch seine Funktionäre haben sich über Jahrzehnte hinweg persönlich am Fußball bereichert. Aber dass es so gekommen ist, war kein Pech oder nur mit Einzelpersonen verbunden. Es entspricht der Funktionsweise des Kapitalismus. Verkürzt gesagt, würde man die FIFA mit denselben Regeln und Strukturen noch einmal neu gründen, in 100 Jahren hätten wir vermutlich denselben korrupten und geldgierigen Haufen an Funktionären. Wenn Raphael von Herrschaftskritik spricht, dann bedeutet das eben auch, in den bestehenden Strukturen wird kein besserer Fußball möglich sein. Und dagegen müssen sich diejenigen auflehnen, auf deren Schultern der Fußballer eigentlich steht – die Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauer in ihrer organisierten Form mit den Ultras. Trotzdem höre ich auch bei ihm Zweifel heraus, ob das klappen kann. Oder vielleicht sind es auch nur meine Zweifel, die ich projiziere. Denn das ist meiner Meinung nach eines der größten Probleme, wenn man über die Zukunft des Fußballs spricht. Wir alle kennen ihn schon so lange und so gut, dass auch die kleinste Veränderung kaum möglich erscheint. Überall stößt man auf Widerstände, vermeintliche Stoppschilder und am Ende landet man wieder beim Status Quo. Vielleicht liegt die Lösung darin, ganz anders auf den Fußball zu schauen. Und zwar so generell, dass die Stoppschilder ganz winzig klein aussehen oder vielleicht ganz verschwinden. Positiv, grundlegend und utopisch, so müsste man auf den Fußball schauen. Ich konnte das bisher noch nicht. Aber Alina Schwamer kann das, denn sie hat ein geradezu bahnbrechendes Buch dazu geschrieben. In Photopia – Ideen für eine bessere Fußballwelt – lässt sich viele der Dinge links liegen über die Christian-Raphael und ich bisher gesprochen haben, weil sie zutief im System Fußball verankert sind und keine Lösung versprechen. Für Alina wirken viele der aktuellen Vorschläge vermutlich, als würde man mit einer Bleiweste versuchen, eine Sprossenleiter hoch zu klettern. Sie denkt so allgemein über den Fußball nach, dass sie seine Grundfesten infrage stellen kann, was ihr ein ganz anderes Denken über die Zukunft des Fußballs ermöglicht. Und sie braucht im Gespräch mit mir handgestoppt nicht mal mehr als 30 Sekunden, um mir das klar zu machen. Die erste Frage ist eine ganz allgemeine. Wenn du dir den Fußball aktuell anschaust, was siehst du dann?
Ich sehe ein System, das nicht funktioniert und von dem ganz viele Leute noch nicht verstanden haben, dass es so nicht funktioniert. Also ich sehe ein System, bei dem ganz viele Leute in ihren Analysen an der Oberfläche kratzen und sich darüber beschweren, dass der FC Bayern zehnmal Meister geworden ist. Das ist ja so das, was eigentlich die Menschen am allermeisten zu berühren scheint und wo ganz viele Menschen der Ansicht sind. Also wenn jetzt der BVB fünfmal Meister würde und der FC Bayern fünfmal bei den Männern wohlgemerkt, dann wäre das schon alles wieder okay und dann hätten wir eigentlich kein Problem mehr. Und ganz grundsätzlich gesprochen gehen die Probleme dieses Systems viel, viel tiefer auf ganz vielen Ebenen und berühren unglaublich auch das, was uns ausmacht. Also was wir glauben, was unsere Gesellschaft ausmacht, indem es zum Beispiel Demokratie massiv unterwandert und zerstört und indem es Menschen extrem einschränkt in der Art und Weise, wie sie Fußball betreiben können, weil man eben Fußball auf bloß eine Art und Weise aktuell betreibt, nämlich die, wie die Verbände sie vorschreiben und in dem Mittel immer weiter bei ganz wenigen Reichen akkumuliert werden. Und ganz viele von diesen Dingen und von Klimakatastrophe haben wir da noch gar nicht gesprochen, sind Sachen, die Menschen nicht so in ihrer Tiefe bewusst sind. Und wenn ich das System Fußball angucke, dann wird ganz, ganz viel gesprochen über so oberflächliche Lösungsgedanken. Aber es wird wenig darüber gesprochen, wie können wir eigentlich dieses System, was ja ein sehr brutales System ist, ein sehr gewaltvolles System ist, anders strukturieren?
Also brutal und gewaltvoll vermutlich, weil es ein System, das ausschließend ist. Also ich muss besser sein, ich muss dominieren und derjenige, der sich da durchsetzt, ist dann der Gewinner und bekommt dafür in allen möglichen Varianten eine Prämie. Dafür, also das meinst du quasi mit gewaltvollem System oder wie verstehst du das?
Das meine ich unter anderem auch mit gewaltvollem System. Ich glaube, gewaltvoll in ganz vielen verschiedenen Komponenten. Also eine, genau die, die du beschrieben hast, das heißt, es geht nur um Sieg und Niederlage, das heißt Kooperation wird nicht honoriert, Kreativität wird nicht honoriert, Demokratie wird nicht honoriert. All die Dinge, die wir eigentlich schätzen als Gesellschaft und von denen wir eigentlich hoffen würden, dass der Fußball sie vielleicht unseren Kindern beibringt und selber beibringt oder zumindest nicht bestraft. Diese Dinge werden durch den Fußball unterdrückt, diese Dinge werden durch den Fußball erschwert oder sogar unmöglich gemacht. Das ist eines der Probleme. Dann ist es aber natürlich auch ein gewaltvolles System in der Art und Weise, wie es ganz viele Menschen benutzt. Also wenn man sich das Ende der Lieferketten anguckt und die Näherinnen, die für wenige Cent Trikots nähen, die dann hierzulande für 89 Euro verkauft werden. Das heißt, am Ende des Systems sitzen ganz viele Menschen, die ganz direkt gewaltvoll ausgebeutet werden. Es ist ein gewaltvolles System in Bezug auf den Planeten, in Bezug auf die Natur, die Ressourcen, die uns in Anführungsstrichen zur Verfügung stehen und die ja gesellschaftliche Mittel sind. Und die von diesem System rücksichtslos verbraucht werden. Es ist ein gewaltvolles System, auch wenn man sich anschaut, wie Menschen darauf reagieren, die da drin sind. Weil ein System, in dem ich mich bewege, das macht ja immer was mit einer Person. Und es gibt so viele Clubs, die mir erzählen von den Kindern, die im Fußball angefangen haben und dann von einem größeren Club gescoutet werden und unter diesem enormen Druck stehen und völlig die Lust am Fußball verlieren, weil es nur noch darum geht, abzuliefern, zu leisten, zu funktionieren und die dann zum kleinen Club zurückgehen, weil sie ausortiert worden sind und einfach keine Lust mehr haben, Fußball zu spielen zum Beispiel, weil ihnen das System die Freude daran genommen hat und wir kennen alle die Aussagen von einigen Profis aus den letzten Jahren, die auch darüber gesprochen haben, dass es nur darum geht, abzuliefern um jeden Preis und dass es auch damit eine ganz konkrete Gewalt, die dem Menschen angetan wird. Und diese vielfache Gewalt, mit der das System funktioniert, das ist Leuten nicht so sehr bewusst. Und vielleicht ein letzter Satz noch dazu, auch nicht so sehr bewusst und das ist auch eine Art von Brutalität, wie viele Menschen das System eigentlich ausschließt. Also zum Beispiel die Tatsache, dass alle Spitzenliegen in Europa, genauer gesagt in Westeuropa, sind. Also wir im Prinzip von so postkolonialen Lieferketten profitieren und der ganz große Teil der Welt überhaupt nur als Zuschauer vor dieser Fensterfront sitzt und überhaupt nicht richtig Teil hat an diesem Fußball. Aber auch die Tatsache, also ganz viele Leute sagen mir, wenn ich so in Podcasts spreche und so, ja aber die Leute wollen ja gar keinen anderen Fußball. So, aber von welchen Leuten sprechen wir, wenn wir sagen, die Leute, ja nur die Leute, die gerade von diesem System mitgenommen werden. Und es gibt schon viele Leute, die mir zum Beispiel sagen, ja ich hätte Bock wieder in den Verein zu gehen, aber nur wenn es anders wäre. Wenn zum Beispiel wir nicht irgendwie gegeneinander spielen, weil mir hat total viel Spaß gemacht damals das Trainieren und das meine eigenen Fähigkeiten zu verbessern und ich muss das gar nicht haben, dass wir jetzt irgendwie in einem Spiel gegeneinander spielen. Und das heißt, wenn wir darüber sprechen, wie können wir den Fußball besser machen und anders machen und Leute sagen, ja aber die Leute wollen gar keinen anderen Fußball, dann reden sie nur über die Leute, für die der aktuelle Fußball gemacht wird. Und alle anderen sind von vornherein aus diesem Fußball ausgeschlossen. Und das vielleicht nur so ein kleiner, abrissend, kleines Beispiel von all den verschiedensten Ebenen, auf denen diese Brutalität funktioniert.
Ich fand es im Gespräch mit Alina damals total irre. Sie zeigt gleich in den ersten Minuten unseres Interviews auf, wie viele Ebenen des Fußballs Menschen ausschließen oder in Gewalt zu führen. Von Näherinnen über Nachwuchstalente bis hin zu Menschen, die sich schon im Fußball ihres Dorfvereins nicht wiederfinden. Was sie dabei vor allem macht, ist, unseren Blick dafür zu öffnen, auf welchen Grundlagen unser heutiger Fußball steht – sowohl auf der Mikroebene, mit zum Beispiel der Frage, wie der Leistungssport in den breiten Sportfußball hineinwirkt, als auch auf der Makroebene mit dem Verweis auf andere Regionen der Welt. Im ersten Moment wirkt das vielleicht etwas unspezifisch, aber wer ein Bewusstsein für diese unterschiedlichen Ebenen entwickelt, nimmt daraus auch etwas für aktuelle Diskussionen mit. Alina macht das anhand eines Beispiels in ihrem Buch anschaulich.
Deutsche Medien klagen gern darüber, wie die deutschen Clubs angeblich den Anschluss verlieren. Kaum eine Zeile widmen sie aber der Tatsache, wie der expandierende deutsche Männerfußball im Gefolge von Premier League und La Liga die Strukturen anderer Länder vernichtet. Heimische Ligen in weiten Teilen Asiens und Afrikas sind durch die Live-Übertragung von europäischem Spitzenfußball völlig bedeutungslos geworden. Ein koloniales Wettrennen um Fernsehzeit, Fans und einen Platz an der Sonne.
Wenn ich jetzt einfach mal so tue, als wäre ich ein Manager eines Männerbundesligisten und ich hätte jetzt eben gerade deine gesammelten Vorwürfe an den Fußball – oder eigentlich ist es eine Situationsbeschreibung, es sind keine Vorwürfe – gehört, dann wäre, glaube ich, der erste Impuls, dass ich sagen würde, ja Moment, aber der Fußball kann doch nichts dafür, dass Lieferketten Menschen ausnutzen, dass in unserer kapitalistischen Welt Dinge so produziert werden, wie sie produziert werden, und dass wir Emissionen ausstoßen, das machen doch ganz viele andere auch. Wie würdest du darauf reagieren?
Würde reagieren mit dem Spruch, keine Gleichheit im Unrecht. Also bloß, weil irgendwas Unrecht ist und weil andere es auch so machen, heißt das ja nicht, dass es legitim ist, dass ich das eben auch tue. Und ich glaube, das ist eine Art und Weise, die Verantwortung von sich zu weisen, wenn man so tut, als könnte man dieses System, in dem man sich bewegt, nicht selbst gestalten. Weil das ist ja im Prinzip diese Reaktion, wenn man also sagt, ich habe damit ja eigentlich gar nichts zu tun, weil ich bewege mich ja in diesem System. Und das ist jetzt wie so ein Pfad, der mir vorgegeben wurde. Und den muss ich ja bestreiten, weil das geht ja gar nicht anders. Und natürlich geht es anders. Und wenn wir uns die Geschichte des Fußballs angucken, dann hat der Fußball ja auch schon ganz oft auf verschiedene Arten und Weisen funktioniert. Das ist ja auch was, was Leuten nicht so bewusst ist. Also wenn wir uns die Struktur des Fußballs angucken, dass es Verbände gibt, dass es Tabellen gibt, dass es Budgets gibt, dass es Profi-Fußball gibt, all das sind ja Entwicklungen, die historisch relativ neu sind. Und davor wurde auch immer schon Fußball gespielt durch die Weltgeschichte hindurch, an verschiedensten Orten, auf ganz verschiedenen Arten und Weisen. Das heißt, dieses System an sich ist viel flexibler, als wir ihm eigentlich zutrauen. Und das finde ich einen ganz, ganz wichtigen Punkt, Leuten überhaupt erst mal diesen Horizont zu eröffnen und bewusst zu machen, dass Fußball in der Art und Weise, wie er funktioniert, völlig fluide ist und auf die verschiedensten Arten und Weisen funktionieren kann. Und dann, wenn ich mich in einem Wirtschaftssystem bewege, dann muss ich natürlich auch anfangen, dieses System kritisch zu hinterfragen und darauf zu reagieren. Und das kann ich ja im Prinzip auf zwei verschiedene Weisen machen. Ich kann das machen, indem ich intern in meinem Fußballsystem was verändere, also indem ich Regeln einführe, indem ich jetzt zum Beispiel – das ist ein ganz plakatives Beispiel, das habe ich relativ am Anfang des Buches – in Australien, wo es das in einigen Sportarten gibt, das Player-Point-System, wo man also sagt, wir haben keine Geld-Obergrenzen, sondern wir haben so eine Art von Kader-Qualitätsobergrenzen und in jedem Club darf nur so und so viel Qualität an Spielerinnen im Kader stehen und wir messen die Qualität anhand eines Punktesystems. Und dann sagt man, jedes Team darf eben nur so und so eine gute elf jetzt im Fußball bezogen auf dem Platz stehen haben. Das heißt dann wirklich direkt auf mein System innerhalb des Fußballs ein. Das hat erstmal überhaupt nichts zu tun mit dem außenstehenden Wirtschaftssystem, sondern ich sage, ich verändere Dinge in unserer Binnenwelt Fußball. Und das wiederum hat Auswirkungen darauf, wie auch die Wirtschaft im Fußball funktioniert. Weil das kann man ja an ganz vielen verschiedenen Stellen tun. Und wenn wir jetzt eben über kooperativen Fußball gesprochen haben oder über Fußball sprechen, wo zum Beispiel Leistung im Vergleich zu den Möglichkeiten honoriert wird, dann ergibt es auch gleich einen völlig anderen Fußball, ohne dass sich das Wirtschaftssystem darum herum umschmeißen muss. Aber natürlich ist es die effizientere Art und Weise, damit umzugehen, wenn ich mir auch Gedanken mache, wie kann ich auf das Wirtschaftssystem drum herum reagieren und wie kann ich das verändern. Und das ist ja auch was, was Klubs auch aktuell tun müssen. Also ganz simples Beispiel, dass die DFL jetzt Nachhaltigkeitskriterien einführt, das ist ja auch nicht ganz umsonst, sondern das ist, weil der gesellschaftliche Druck so groß ist. Das heißt, so oder so ist Fußball kein unveränderliches System, sondern es ist eines, das immer reagieren muss auf das, was außerhalb passiert und was außerhalb wirtschaftlich passiert. Und natürlich kann ich den Spieß auch umdrehen und das muss ich sogar, wenn ich unzufrieden bin mit der Art und Weise, wie der Fußball aktuell ist. Das heißt, nicht nur da sitzen und sagen, ja der Fußball, wie er ist, ist aktuell irgendwie doof und es liegt aber daran, dass die Wirtschaft doof ist und also kann ich da nichts machen, sondern sagen, die Probleme, die wir aktuell im Fußball sehen, sehen wir auch in der Wirtschaft. Also gehen wir vom Fußball aus, weil Fußball ja was ist, was unglaublich doll Menschen zusammenfühlt, was sehr plastisch ist. Also, wenn mein Verein sehr prekär ist, wenn er absteigt, weil er keine Geldmittel zur Verfügung hat zum Beispiel oder wenn ich die Entscheidung treffe, meine Mitspracherechte abzugeben, weil ich einen Investor brauche, um in diesem System zu funktionieren, das heißt, mir die Demokratie verloren geht im Club, dann sind das Dinge, wo Menschen, die sich vielleicht sonst nicht so viel damit auseinandersetzen, ganz konkret sehen, wie diese Wirtschaft funktioniert und woran sie scheitert. Und das macht den Fußball zu einer eigentlich total schönen Plattform, um Menschen bestimmte Dinge bewusst zu machen, die ihnen nicht bewusst sind und über den Fußball anzufangen, sich Gedanken zu machen, wie kann man das anders strukturieren und über den Fußball vielleicht auch Veränderungen ins Gesamtsystem zu tragen.
Du schreibst dazu, dieser Fußball ist eine Schule für die Allmacht des Geldes, seine Mechanismen liegen offen wie ein Buch und Menschen können hier Dinge sehen, die in der unübersichtlichen Gesellschaft sonst diskreter sind. Das führt aber natürlich auch dazu, dass, wenn man so über den Fußball denkt und logischerweise dann damit auch über unsere Gesellschaft, unser Wirtschaftssystem, in dem wir leben und so weiter und so fort, man zu sehr radikalen Lösungen kommt. Und ich glaube, sie klingen in den Ohren mancher, die mit dem Fußball bisher vielleicht vor allem den Leistungsfußball der Männer gemeint haben und aber einmal vom Fußball gesprochen haben, da klingt das, glaube ich, sehr radikal und unrealistisch und ich glaube, die Abwehrmechanismen sind bei so etwas sehr groß. Wie kann man denn diese Diskussion so führen, dass man die Probleme, die es gibt, anerkennt, auch anerkennt, dass nicht der Fußball an allem schuld ist, dass er aber mit Profiteur ist eines Systems, das sich auch in allen anderen Gesellschaftsbereichen etabliert hat und dass man aber dennoch das Produktiv für sich nutzen kann, jetzt über den Fußball dann eben erst einen Erkenntnisgewinn anzustoßen? Ich glaube, das ist das, was du jetzt gerade getan hast, in dem du das mal aufgezeigt hast, und dann aber ja auch einen konstruktiven Veränderungsprozess loszutreten.
Ja, absolut. Also erstmal, was ich vielleicht noch sagen möchte, dieses Wort radikal finde ich sehr lustig, weil das höre ich sehr, sehr oft. Das ist wahrscheinlich das am häufigsten assoziierte Adjektiv mit diesem Buch.
Was ja eigentlich gut ist, das heißt, dass du zu den Wurzeln gehst, also daher kommt ja radikal.
Ja und ich finde es aber so krass oft, dass dieses Wort benutzt wird, weil wenn man das jetzt mal, also wenn man nicht davon ausgeht, von der Wurzel des Wortes, sondern von dem aktuellen Kontext, in dem es gemeint ist, also diese Reaktion, das ist aber krass und ja es hat ja auch so einen negativen Beiklang, radikal für viele Menschen. Und ich finde das System, in dem sich gerade der Fußball bewegt, das ist ja eigentlich total radikal. Also das ist ein super radikales System, wenn man sagt, dass zwölf Clubs in Europa mehr Geld machen als die 700 anderen Erstligisten zusammen. Das ist total radikal. Oder wenn man sagt, dass von unseren gesellschaftlichen Mitteln, die wir zur Verfügung haben, ein Club, das ist in dem Fall der BVB, in zehn Jahren 1, 3 Milliarden für Transfers ausgegeben hat, wovon kein einziger Cent nötig ist, weil Ablösesummen sowieso eigentlich völlig unnötig sind ökonomisch. Und das ist völlig radikal. Nicht zuletzt, wenn man ein System hat, das irgendwie sagt, ja, dass wir jetzt nur noch zehn Jahre haben, um das Schlimmste an der Klimakatastrophe abzuwenden, das ist uns egal und machen wir einfach mal weiter wie gehabt.
Wie könnt ihr euch auf die Straße kleben? Man denkt sich so, na ja, wie können wir alle sterben?
Ja, und das ist eigentlich ein total radikales System. Und das ist, was Leuten bewusst werden muss erstmal. Und dann, glaube ich, es hat ganz viel zu tun mit Gewöhnung. Also viele Leute haben mir gesagt, dass das, was sie da lesen in dem Buch, dass das krass ihren Horizont eröffnet hat, aber dass es sie gleichzeitig auch überfordert und dass es gleichzeitig diese Abwehrmechanismen in ihnen weckt, von denen du redest. Also dieses, ja, aber ich habe doch jetzt 30 Jahre Fußball so gespielt, wie er gerade ist und ich verbinde damit ja auch ganz viele schöne Erinnerungen. Und warum soll das denn jetzt alles schlecht sein und so weiter? Es gibt ja einen ganz interessanten Mechanismus, der im Prinzip gesagt, je mehr ich etwas ausgesetzt werde, einer Meinung, einer Theorie, einem Konzept und so weiter, desto positiver erscheint es mir. Das heißt, es ist ganz wichtig überhaupt erst mal anzufangen, über Alternativen zu reden und Leute dem regelmäßig auszusetzen. Also es reicht nicht, wenn ich an irgendeinen Ort gehe und wir reden da 90 Minuten irgendwie über, was im Fußball schlecht läuft und wie man das anders machen kann, weil das führt im besten Falle dazu, dass Leute einen gewissen Denkanstoß haben, aber das führt jetzt nicht dazu, dass Leute sich hinstellen und sagen, kommen wir gründen jetzt eine Bewegung, die das alles ganz anders macht, das reicht nicht aus. Und das heißt, dass wir den Diskurs verstetigen müssen, also dass wir im Idealfall sowas brauchen, wie ein Institut für Sport-Utopie, was erstmal überhaupt die ganzen Leute, die ja schon aktiv sind im Fußball, weil es gibt ja Nester, nenne ich sie jetzt mal, wo an einem besseren Fußball gearbeitet wird und viele davon zitiere ich in dem Buch, diese verschiedenen Menschen zusammenzubringen, also dafür zu sorgen, sich wirklich die Zeit zu nehmen. Zeit ist im Kapitalismus immer ein Riesenproblem, weil wir alle in der Lohnarbeit festhängen. Sich die Zeit zu nehmen, wirklich in Workshops an Alternativen zu basteln, Dinge auszuhandeln, so ähnlich, wie das die Taskforce Profi-Fußball ein bisschen anders getan hat in der DSL. Aber das ist ja grundsätzlich, also vom Konzept her, wenn wir jetzt mal die Machtmechanismen und so weiter außen vor lassen, ist es ja eine gute Idee, sich regelmäßig zusammenzusetzen und zu sagen, wir erarbeiten überhaupt erst Stück für Stück Alternativen. Und das ist ja der erste Schritt, im Prinzip, den ich in der Buchunternehmen, in dem ich sage, ich stelle jetzt erst mal Alternativen in den Raum und ihr könnt euch jetzt erst mal sozusagen im Positiven und im Negativen damit auseinandersetzen, daran auslassen, Widerspruch leisten, weil das sorgt ja erst dafür, dass Konzepte sich weiterentwickeln, wenn irgendjemand sagt, ja hey, eigentlich finde ich das ganz gut, aber diesen Punkt, den finde ich überhaupt nicht gut. Und dann kommt man an den Punkt zu sagen, wie könnten wir diesen Punkt anders machen, sodass er besser funktioniert – also zu einem funktionierenden Konzept gehört ja nicht eine Person, sondern gehören immer so viele wie möglich, die an dem Prozess teilnehmen. Und wenn wir an dem Prozess sind, dass wir wirklich Hebel ausgehandelt haben, von dem wir sagen, genau die drei sind uns die wichtigsten, davon glauben wir, dass das am meisten verändern könnte in halbwegs plausibler Zeit. Und die fordern wir jetzt ein und die tragen wir so in den Mainstream, dass eine Druckwelle entsteht. Also im Prinzip die Druckwelle, von der wir ja reden, wenn wir uns angucken, was in den letzten 20 Jahren beim Thema Rassismus passiert ist, was beim Thema Sexismus passiert ist, was beim Thema Klima gerade beginnt zu passieren im Fußball. Das sind ja alles solche Druckwellen, die reingetragen wurden in den Fußball. Und ich glaube aber, dass das Thema Wirtschaft eins ist, vor dem viele Leute ein bisschen Angst haben, weil es über die Selbstbetroffenheit hinausgeht. So bei Rassismus oder bei Sexismus bin ich sehr offensichtlich selber betroffen. Und da fällt es irgendwie leichter, sich mit Betroffenen zusammenzuschließen. Und bei diesem Thema ist es schwieriger. Deshalb, glaube ich unter anderem – also es gibt viele Gründe – aber deshalb unter anderem ist es bisher nicht passiert. Aber man kann ja von den anderen Bewegungen lernen. Und man sieht anhand dieser anderen Bewegungen, dass sie schon in bestimmtem Rahmen sehr viel bewegt im Fußball. Das kastet aber aktuell nicht die Geldströme an, weil da natürlich die Widerstandskräfte viel größer sind. Und das heißt, der Prozess der Vorbereitung muss länger werden. Das heißt, der Prozess erstmal bei den Leuten selber die Zäune der Verteidigung ein bisschen ganz sanft niederzureißen und dann in die gesellschaftliche Auseinandersetzung zu gehen und dann in die Forderung zu gehen. Das sind, glaube ich, so drei Schritte, die sehr wichtig sind.
Ist euch auch aufgefallen, wie nahe wir hier Raphael Meuter mit seinen Gedanken zur Deutsche Wohnen und Co. enteignen kommen? Auch Alina orientiert sich am positiven Beispiel für Aktivismus, wenn auch auf einer anderen Ebene. Bezogen auf den Fußball ist es dann schon fast zu eindeutig. Christian Spiller, Raphael Meuter, Alina Schwärmer – alle landen in ihrer Problembeschreibung immer beim Wirtschaftssystem des Fußballs. Klar, könnte auch daran liegen, dass die Verteilung von Reichtum auch in unsere Gesellschaft darüber mitbestimmt, ob und wie wir an ihr teilhaben können.
Wenn wir darauf gucken, wie ungleich unsere Gesellschaft ist, dann ist der wichtigste Ausschlussfaktor in Vereinen, zum Beispiel in Fußballvereinen, es nicht die Hautfarbe oder das Geschlecht, sondern der wichtigste Ausschlussfaktor ist Armut. Das ist was, was in der Debatte überhaupt nicht präsent ist. Es wird nicht gesehen, dass es für Menschen in Armut faktisch völlig unmöglich ist, dass in irgendeinem Gremium eines Fußballvereins zu sitzen. Also zunächst mal kommen sie ganz oft gar nicht erst in die Vereine rein, weil eben ganz viele soziale, gesellschaftliche Hürden bestehen. Aber in einem Fußballverein an der Spitze muss ich Kontakte haben, muss ich gute Kontakte in die lokale Wirtschaft haben, zu lokalen Firmen haben, im Idealfall oft selber in eine Firma führen. Also im Amateurfußball ist das Konzept der Investor, der gleichzeitig Präsident sehr populär. Das ist etwas, was überhaupt nicht bewusst ist in der Debatte, wer eigentlich wirklich total massiv aus diesem Fußball ausgeschlossen ist. Und um zu kommen auf die Gruppen, die gerade in den letzten Jahrzehnten viel für ihre Rechte gekämpft haben im Fußball, das sind eben Gruppen, von denen einzelne Mitglieder zu gesellschaftlicher Anerkennung, zu gesellschaftlichem Wohlstand kommen können und damit die Mittel haben, für ihre Rechte zu streiten. Wenn ich aber arm bin, wenn ich marginalisiert bin, wenn ich prekär bin, dann gibt es automatisch niemanden aus der Gruppe, der für diese Rechte streiten kann oder sehr, sehr wenige, weil sie eben prekär sind und das heißt, dass das ein ganz, ganz mächtiger Ausschlussfaktor ist, diese Ungleichheit. Und das sehen wir ja auch im Fußball, das sehen wir ja auch, wenn Amateur-Vereine zum Beispiel versuchen, sich zu organisieren gegen die Großen und das fällt ihnen ganz, ganz schwer, weil sie eben so wahnsinnig viele andere Dinge haben, die sie im Alltag beschäftigen, weil diese Menschen gleichzeitig noch ein Verein zu führen haben. Natürlich nicht zu vergessen, dass die Profis wahnsinnig wichtig sind finanziell und dass die ganz andere Möglichkeiten haben, ihre Interessen durchzusetzen. Und das ist eigentlich auch ein schönes Beispiel dafür, dass es den Prekären, den Ausgeschlossenen sehr schwer fällt, ihre Interessen durchzusetzen. Viel schwerer interessanterweise als zum Beispiel Fans. Also Fans sind ja viel wirkungsvoller darin, für ihre Interessen zumindest zu streiten, durchsetzen tun sie sie auch nicht allzu oft, als dass beispielsweise kleine Amateurklubs sind, also diese riesige zersplitterte Masse.
Gerade weil wir oft nur über den Profifußball sprechen, ist dieser Einschub von Alina wichtig. Selbst wenn wir im Spitzensegment des Fußballs absolute Gleichheit hätten, wäre der Fußball in sich immer noch unterdrückend gegenüber denjenigen, die sich nicht so gut organisieren können. Und oft hängt das mit Armut zusammen. Ich halte das deshalb für einen wichtigen Aspekt, weil wir bei der Diskussion über die Zukunft des Fußballs oft über Ungleichheit sprechen, damit aber die Ungleichheit innerhalb der Superreichen meinen. Das muss man nicht per se problematisieren, man sollte sich dessen aber bewusst sein. Wenn wir uns den Fußball als Pyramide von Gizy vorstellen, dann sprechen wir auch in dieser Sendung oft nur über die obersten 10 cm. Der Breitensport, das riesige Fundament, geht dabei genauso unter wie all jene, die schon vom Breitensport ausgeschlossen werden, also nicht mal Teil der Pyramide sein dürfen, sondern nur Sandkörner zu ihren Füßen. Gut, immerhin Sandkörner, die in die Illusoren gegeben wird, dass wenn sie sich nur ganz doll anstrengen, sie auch irgendwann ein Stein in der Pyramide sein dürfen.
Es gibt ja total interessante Studien über Glück und so weiter, die halt sagen, in einer ungleichen Gesellschaft herrscht grundsätzlich weniger Glücklichkeit, weniger Zufriedenheit und auch die Reichen sind unglücklicher, weil diese Gewalt, diese Brutalität, jetzt kommen wir wieder auf das zurück, worüber wir am Anfang besprochen haben, die macht auch was mit denen, die sie anwenden. Die macht nicht nur was mit den Betroffenen, sondern die macht auch was mit denen, die sie anwenden. Und das heißt, es ist für beide Seiten, es ist einfach die viel klügere Lösung, Gleiche zu verteilen, also ein System zu schaffen, was die Menschen, die daran teilnehmen, glücklich macht. Und das hat viel zu tun mit Solidaritäten, das hat viel damit zu tun, als Gesellschaft zu funktionieren. Und ich glaube, die Gründe, warum das trotzdem so oft nicht funktioniert – also es ist jetzt sehr komplex, aber reißen wir das nun mal irgendwie zwei Sekunden an – hat natürlich zum einen damit zu tun, dass die Herrschenden kein Interesse daran haben, also dass die Herrschenden Interesse daran haben, ihre Herrschaft auszubauen und dass sie dann so Erzählungen schaffen, die diese Herrschaft stützen und die Erzählung ist ja immer aktuell, ja die da oben stehen, die haben sich das ja verdient. Das höre ich auch ganz oft im Fußball und das ist manchmal ganz absurd. Also ich habe zum Beispiel, um mal wieder ein plastisches Beispiel aus dem Fußball zu schaffen, letztes Jahr mit einer Spielerin gesprochen von Carl Zeiss Jena, die standen total unten in der Frauenbundesliga, hatten natürlich überhaupt keine Chance zu konkurrieren irgendwie mit dem FC Bayern oder dem VfL Wolfsburg und dann habe ich gesagt, ja wäre es nicht eigentlich sinnvoll für euch, wenn der DFB zum Beispiel einen separaten Topf schafft, von dem aus er euch unterstützt, damit ihr konkurrenzfähig sein könnt und dann hat sie mir gesagt sinngemäß, ja ja, das wäre schon schön für uns, aber die großen Vereine, das muss man ja auch sehen, die haben sich das ja erarbeitet und die haben sich das ja verdient und von daher wäre das unverdehend gegenüber.
Was ja nicht mal stimmt, die großen Vereine im Frauenfußball machen ja Schulden, während die kleinen Vereine zum großen Teil auf einer schwarzen Null arbeiten.
Und ob man sich das so erarbeitet hat, wenn VW einen unterstützt, das ist dann halt auch so eine Frage.
Genau, das kommt noch dazu.
Also das kommt noch dazu. Und das ist eine Ideologie, die unglaublich wirkmächtig ist und die gerade auch unglaublich wirkmächtig ist, bei denen, die eigentlich davon profitieren würden, wenn man anders verteilt. Und das heißt, Erzählungen sind sehr, sehr mächtig. Was auch unglaublich mächtig ist, ist der Nationalstaat. Also der Gedanke, dass Abwanderung verhindert wird. Das ist ja sehr interessant. Also üblicherweise wäre es ja so, wenn ich mich auf einem Territorium befinde und irgendjemand da behandelt mich total scheiße und ich habe überhaupt keine Chancen, dann würde ich sagen, ja, gehe ich halt woanders hin. Mir ist es viel zu blöd hier. Aber das kannst du nicht. Also zumindest nicht, wenn du in einem prekären Staat lebst, weil man lässt dich eben halt nicht raus. Und das ist was, was wahnsinnig wirkmächtig herrscht und manifestiert, weil du ja keine Möglichkeit hast, zu protestieren, indem du weggehst. Das kannst du nicht machen. Und das wäre ja ein sehr interessantes Konzept, wenn man jetzt sagt, es gibt keine festen Grenzen und jeder kann eben dahin gehen, wo es ihm am besten gefällt. Und das wäre wahrscheinlich eine sehr demokratische Möglichkeit, rauszufinden, was ein sinnvolles System ist. Weil ein System, was gut funktioniert, da würden dann ja wahrscheinlich sehr viele Leute hinstreben. Aber diese demokratische Abstimmungswirklichkeit habe ich eben nicht. Das sind jetzt so zwei Beispiele, die, glaube ich, vielleicht verdeutlichen können, warum man trotz, also obwohl das total irrational ist, eigentlich, was wir machen. Und wenn irgendein Alien vom Mars herkäme, und der würde sich wahrscheinlich nur an den Kopf fassen, was wir tun.
Wenn er einen Kopf hätte, ja.
Wenn er einen Kopf hätte, ja. Da könnte man jetzt lange diskutieren, wie konventionell Aliens aussehen in den Filmen. Die sehen ja auch immer alle gleich aus.
Ja, so viel dazu. Ich merke schon, wir könnten mit dir sehr grundsätzlich reden. Ich habe auch, mein Gefühl ist, es reduziert sich immer am Schluss darauf, dass Angst eine der stärksten Emotionen ist, die Angst, etwas zu verlieren, die Angst vor dem Fremden und so weiter. Aber bevor wir jetzt noch tiefer ins Psychologische einsteigen und die Nationalstaaten und alles auflösen, würde ich dir gerne die Frage stellen, warum hat es denn dann überhaupt einen Wert über so etwas Bedeutungsloses letztlich dann ja doch, wie Geldverteilung im Männerfußball zu sprechen?
Es hat den Wert, dass ich natürlich viel daran illustrieren kann und darüber zu den größeren Fragen kommen kann. Aber ich habe auch das Gefühl, wenn wir jetzt auf diese aktuellen Diskussionen gucken, diese TV-Geldumverteilung und wo es ja auch letztlich also was eine total elitäre Diskussion ist, weil es geht jedes Mal darum, innerhalb Deutschlands, innerhalb des Männerfußballs, innerhalb des Männerprofi-Fußballs in der obersten Liga Dinge umzuverteilen. Das ist ja im Grunde, warum sich die Diskussion dreht. Das heißt, es ist eine total elitäre Debatte und die habe ich tatsächlich das Gefühl, dass die nicht zu viel führt. Das hat aber auch damit zu tun, dass die Machtverhältnisse so sind, wie sie aktuell sind und dass die Debatte nicht an die Machtverhältnisse rangeht. Also sie geht nicht daran, wie können wir jetzt dem FC Bayern seinen großen Einfluss nehmen, sondern sie sagt, ja das wäre irgendwie schön, wenn wir das wieder umverteilen würden und sagt der FC Bayern, nee finde ich aber blöd und dann ist die Debatte wieder vorbei. Und manchmal kommt ja auch das Argument, wenn ich so über Ideen rede, ja deine Ideen, die sind ja total unrealistisch, die lassen sich ja eh nicht umsetzen. Aber der Witz ist, also erstens hat noch überhaupt niemand versucht, aber zweitens, diese vermeintlich realistischen Reformen, die lassen sich erst recht nicht umsetzen. Wir reden seit 30 Jahren darüber, dass es schön wäre, wieder Gleicher zu verteilen im Profifußball der Männer. Und das passiert überhaupt nicht. Es geht immer in die entgegengesetzte Richtung, weil eben das System und die Machtverhältnisse das verhindern. Und das heißt, Leute haben immer so einen Impuls, darüber zu sprechen, über das, was irgendwie greifbar ist und was sehr leicht erreichbar scheint. Und oft ist das aber viel, viel schwieriger erreichbar oder sogar unmöglich erreichbar, weil eben das grundsätzliche Gebilde, in dem wir uns bewegen, das völlig unmöglich macht. Und ich glaube, das wäre gut, wenn wir jetzt über Geldverteilung im Männerfußball sprechen, wenn die öffentliche Debatte das beginnt zu verstehen. Also dieses Das Das, worauf sie immer wieder pochen, auf diese kleinen oberflächlichen Reformen, dass die erstens kaum erreichbar sind, also viel unrealistischer, als wenn wir uns mit Grundsätzen auseinandersetzen und das zweitens auch ganz, ganz viel Frustration verursacht. Also ein Großteil der Frustration im Fußball kommt ja von dem Gedanken, wir können ja eh nichts ändern. Aus der Erfahrung heraus, dass diese ganzen Debatten der letzten 30 Jahre in Bezug auf Wirtschaft letztlich nur Niederlagen eingefahren haben. Und daher kommt eine wahnsinnig große Frustration und daher kommt auch so eine wachsende Gleichgültigkeit teilweise demgegenüber. Und wenn wir aber anfangen, über Grundsätze zu sprechen, dann können wir natürlich wahnsinnig viel verändern. Aber das tun wir überhaupt nicht. Also wir fangen überhaupt nicht an, über Grundsätze zu sprechen. Und das heißt, der Reformwunsch im Fußball oder die Revolte im Fußball, wenn ich es mal provokanter formuliere, macht sich auch immer ein Stück weit selber kaputt, indem sie sich einfach permanent aufs falsche Pferd setzen. Und es wirft sie wieder ab und sie setzen sich immer wieder drauf.
Also das verstehe ich und wird dem auch inhaltlich zustimmen. Gleichzeitig glaube ich, aber du bist dann mit dem, was du da sagst, du bist gedanklich einfach schon ein paar Jahre weiter, weil du dich schon so intensiv mit diesem Thema auseinandersetzt. Und weil du ein ganzes Füllhorn – kann man ja alles sehr schön nachlesen in Futopia – an Utopien auch schon durchdacht hast, angewandt hast auf den Fußball. Deswegen bist du weiter. Ich würde jetzt die These dir vor die Füße werfen, dass es zwar stimmt, dass solche Diskussionen wie 50 plus 1, Salary Cap, Financial Fair Play, Play of Super League – ich glaube, das sind jetzt so gerade so die Dauerbrenner, die es gerade so gibt – dass es zwar stimmt, dass die an dem grundsätzlichen Problem nichts verändern. Ich könnte mir aber vorstellen, dass es notwendig ist, wo anzufangen, nicht nur mit Reformen, sondern auch mit einer Diskussion. Und dass das Radikale – also ich meine radikal immer zu den Wurzeln gehend – überfordernd ist. In einer Welt, in der es ja auch nicht so ist, dass sonst gerade nichts passieren würde – also wir haben ja nicht nur den Fußball als größtes Problem – da ist es auch wirklich herausfordernd, vielleicht von einer größeren Masse zu fordern, dass die ihren Horizont so erweitern können, ohne dass ich jetzt sagen will, na doch, sie haben einen eingeschränkten Horizont, aber ich will ihnen das nicht zum Vorwurf machen. Also ich meine, das ist jetzt nicht despektierlich. Also kann nicht darin auch ein Wert liegen, dass man eben dann doch noch mal über 50 plus einspricht, auch wenn es natürlich eigentlich trotzdem – da sitzen quasi 18 Leute ganz oben auf der Pyramide und sagen, wie können wir die fünf Zentimeter zu dem, der auf der Spitze sitzt, verkürzen? Das ist ja quasi das Absurde eigentlich, dass wir halt hier über eine elitäre Diskussion sprechen, aber kann sie nicht daraus dann doch einen Wert kreieren, generieren?
Ich glaube grundsätzlich, es ist total wichtig, auch über kleine, anfassbare Dinge zu sprechen, und genau das mache ich auch ganz, ganz viel in dem Buch. Also ganz, ganz viele kleine Mechanismen, die sofort umsetzbar wären, aber man muss gucken, welche Mechanismen sind das. Also, ich muss über die richtigen Mechanismen sprechen und nicht über die falschen, weil bei 50 plus 1 zum Beispiel ist das große Problem, dass es ja eigentlich nichts verändert an ganz vielen Dingen, die uns so wahnsinnig stören im Fußball oder die wahnsinnig problematisch sind im Fußball. Also, bestes Beispiel, wenn wir gerade sprechen über den Amateurfußball und dieses Ganze. Der Investor ist auch der Präsident und der Amateurfußball ist super undemokratisch und ich bezahle immer mehr Geld dafür, in der gleichen Liga zu spielen und der Spaß geht verloren, der Zusammenhalt geht verloren, ich muss Spieler von außerhalb zukaufen, um da mithalten zu können und so weiter. Und all diese Dinge werden ja durch 50 plus 1 überhaupt nicht verändert oder angefasst und wir sehen auch in Deutschland, wie viele Möglichkeiten – es gibt sehr wirksam – 50 plus 1 zu benutzen und gleichzeitig zu machen, was man möchte. Also, Hertha BSC und das Konzept Windhorst, das ist im Sinne von 50 plus 1, ich bin mir sicher, das ist es eigentlich nicht, aber es funktioniert im Rahmen von 50 plus 1. Und das heißt, wenn wir über greifbare Dinge reden, dann müssen wir über Dinge reden, die greifbar sind und die auch was verändern. Also zum Beispiel, indem wir sagen, wir machen ein finanzielles 50 plus 1 und wir sagen, 51 Prozent der Mittel, die Clubs haben, müssen von ihren Mitgliedern oder von den Fans kommen. Und das ist ein sehr wirksames Konzept, um dafür zu sorgen, dass Sponsoren und Investoren weniger Einfluss haben, weil im Prinzip kommt der Einfluss ja nicht so sehr durch Stimmrechte, dadurch kommt der auch, aber Einfluss hat der, der Geld gibt. Der hat das Sagen und das heißt, ich muss, um wieder auf das Wort radikal zurückzukommen, ich muss da an die Wurzel gehen und sagen, okay, also ich sehe, wer das Geld gibt, hat das Sagen. Okay, dann sorgen wir dafür, dass 51 Prozent der Mittel von Fans und Mitgliedern stammen müssen, direkt oder indirekt, kann durch Ticketverkauf sein, durch Merch, durch Mitgliederbeiträge und so weiter und so fort, was übrigens gleichzeitig auf sehr angenehme Weise diese absurden Summen im Fußball ziemlich drastisch reduzieren würde. Oder wir können über ein Werbeverbot im Fußball nachdenken. Das ist ja auch total absurd, wenn man darüber nachdenkt. Der Fußball könnte sich auf seinen Trikots alles bewerben, aber dass er das Kaufen verkauft, das ist ja auch völlig interessant und das müsste überhaupt nicht so sein. Und warum muss das so sein? Und wenn wir ein Werbeverbot im Fußball einführen, dann hat das auch ganz massive Konsequenzen darauf, wie Sponsoren dem gegenüber agieren. Also wir können natürlich über ganz, ganz viele ganz konkrete kleine Dinge sprechen, aber dann bitte über die Dinge, die auch wirklich was verändern. Und ich mache damit auch ganz gute Erfahrungen, wenn man zum Beispiel jetzt bei kleinen Vereinen ist und man sagt ja, ihr könnt ganz im Kleinen anfangen, indem ihr zum Beispiel einfach anders spielt. Also indem ihr einfach im Training mal andere Spiele macht, wo es im Fußball um Humor geht oder um Kooperation geht oder wo man den Fußball selber, Demokratie überhaupt, erstmal die Regeln aushandelt und es finden die total cool und sagen ja klar kann man irgendwie ausprobieren, weil das Sachen sind, die sehr greifbar sind, wo man sich nicht erstmal mit dem DFB anlegen muss, sondern man kann die im kleinen Rahmen auf dem eigenen Platz irgendwie ausprobieren und wenn man Bock hat, kann man ein paar Clubs finden, die da auch daran Interesse haben, kann man ein Turnier machen mit einer neuen Spielform. Also es gibt ganz, ganz viele Dinge, die man sofort, die ich morgen irgendwie mit elf Freundinnen umsetzen kann, aber dann müssen wir über die richtigen Dinge sprechen und nicht über die falschen.
In Futopia widmet sich Alina deshalb all den Vorschlägen, die gerade so kursieren zur Verbesserung des Fußballs. Gehaltsobergrenze, das Ben & Jerrys der Fußballreform, das Tröpfchen Revolution, das auch dem Wall Street-Mann schmeckt. Sieht gut aus, funktioniert aber nicht. Nicht mal im US-Sport, der so oft als Vorbild genommen wird. Untersuchungen haben gezeigt, dass ein Salary Cap-League sogar oft noch weniger ausgeglichen macht. Ein Draft-System? In den USA dient es vor allem dafür, die Gehälter der Sportlerinnen und Sportler zu drücken. Deshalb wurde es im Jahr 1935 in der NFL überhaupt erfunden. Man müsste also den vom System betroffenen mehr Rechte verschaffen und gleichzeitig steuern, dass schlechtere Vereine gegenüber besseren im Vorteil sind. Umverteilung des vorhandenen Geldes? Kann kurzfristig helfen, wird aber langfristig immer wieder zum alten Zustand führen, wenn das dahinter liegende Wirtschaftskonzept gleich bleibt. Generieren von mehr Geld? Erstmal sorgt Geld für Gleichheit. Alina schreibt.
Mehr Geldmittel machen eine Liga gleicher, nicht ungleicher. Reichere Länder haben ausgeglichenere Fußball-Ligen als ärmere Länder. Frauenfußball in Europa ist unausgeglichener als die Männer-Ligen. Reiche Ligen sind, entgegen populärer Annahmen, gleicher als Arme – siehe Premier League. Und es gilt, soll eine Liga ausgeglichener werden, muss es mehr Investment geben. Es gilt aber auch, die anderen Ligen sind arm und ungleich, weil so viel Investment in einige wenige fließt.
Die Probleme beginnen aber bei der Frage, womit das Geld generiert wird. Mehr TV-Einnahmen für alle ändert nichts wesentlich an der Ungleichheit. Selbst eine Gleichverteilung würde vor allem die untere Hälfte der Liga unter Druck setzen, wie wir ja auch schon vorhin gehört haben. Viel wichtiger für die Ungleichheit in einer Liga sind Sponsoren und Metzene. Deren Gelder gelten aber als unverteilbar. Alina zeigt mit vielen Beispielen auf, wie durch eine bessere Geldverteilung mehr Gleichheit geschaffen werden kann. Aber ohne solche Lösungsansätze wie ihre zementiert neues Geld lediglich die bestehenden Zustände. Und wenn die Rich Kids in eine Superliga verschwinden würden, würde das was verändern? Na zumindest nichts daran, dass sich Besitz im Fußball an seiner Spitze konzentriert.
Oder wie Alina schreibt, Einen Systemfehler behäbt man nicht, indem man Reiche woanders hinziehen lässt, sondern indem man Reichen Macht und Besitz nimmt und dann anders organisiert. Der Fußball muss eine eigene Antwort auf die Globalisierung geben.
Zu dieser Antwort gehört, die Wirkung von Ligen zu hinterfragen. Hierzulande sind Fußball-Ligen offen, es gibt einen Auf- und Abstieg. Aber vor allem der Abstieg ist so brutal, dass ein Verdrängungswettbewerb einsetzt, der wenig innovativ und nachhaltig ist. Geschlossene Ligen wie im US-Sport sind an der Spitze ausgeglichener, dafür schließen sie dann ganze Städte und Regionen aus. Wer eine Super League möchte und sich davon eine positive Veränderung des Fußballs erhofft, müsste sie ganz anders denken. Ein Beispiel. Wir haben uns daran gewöhnt, dass Ligen vertikal gestaffelt sind, oben die erste Liga, darunter die zweite, darunter eine dritte und so weiter und so fort. Warum aber denkt man nicht öfter an ein Nebeneinander von Ligen? Alina schreibt zum Beispiel.
Auch eine faire Weltliga ist möglich. Zum Beispiel mit einem starken und einem schwachen Baum und neu eingeteilten, etwa gleich starken Heimat-Ligen, wo der FC Bayern mit Rapid Wien spielt und Turbine Potsdam mit Katowice. Es braucht offene Grenzen für Clubs und für einen fairen Wettbewerb, dies alle bekommen vor jeder Saison gleich viel Geld.
Ich weiß, der Vergleich kommt jetzt aus dem Nichts und er ist auch meiner und nicht der von Alina. Aber könnte nicht ein oft so belächelter Wettbewerb wie die Nations League ein Hinweis darauf sein, wie man Wettbewerb auch gestalten kann? Hier spielen gestaffelt nach Stärke nebeneinander mehrere Nationen miteinander, es gibt auf allen Ebenen Wettbewerb und vor allem die kleineren Nationen profitieren davon. In sich ist das System geschlossen, aber innerhalb der einzelnen Stufen offen. Was würde passieren, wenn wir das mit europäischen Vereinen gestalten und dann alle gleich viel Geld bekommen? Alina denkt das in ihrem Buch sogar noch weiter, sie spricht von ganzen Galaxien an nebeneinander stehenden Ligen. Warum sollte das Verkaufsargument einer Liga so wie jetzt sein, dass sich die Vereine nach Leistung qualifiziert haben? Möglich wäre doch auch eine Traditionsliga, eine Liga von Fans geführten Clubs, eine Liga für Ultra-Kultur mit Pyrotechnik und vieles mehr. Wichtig ist vor allem, bestehende Machtverhältnisse zu brechen und im Vorhinein über eine gerechte Verteilung der Ressourcen zu verhandeln. Ab dann ist eigentlich alles denkbar – also zumindest theoretisch. Einige der Vorschläge von Alina sind kurzfristig nicht umsetzbar, zum Teil noch nicht mal innerhalb von Jahren. Was aber können wir jetzt schon tun, um den Fußball zu verbessern?
Ich glaube, es braucht eine gute Kombination aus Dingen, die ich mittelfristig einführen kann und gleichzeitig aber nicht so sehr sich in diesem Reformismus zu verrennen. Das ist etwas, was ich gerade jetzt so viel beobachte. Man sagt, man möchte etwas Kleines haben, was greifbar ist und so weiter. Das sind dann aber auch Dinge, die trotzdem sehr lange brauchen, um erkämpft zu werden. Vielleicht verliert man darüber dann auch ein Stück weit den Blick für die systemischen Dinge. Das heißt, man muss eine gute Balance schaffen. Ich will immer so ungern die Klimakatastrophe als den Gott aus der Maschine nutzen, der uns in das neue System bringt. Aber wir haben nicht mehr furchtbar viel Zeit, um das System grundlegend umzustrukturieren. Auch das müssen Leute verstehen. Also es ist nicht getan damit, wenn man die ganze Zeit weiter über 50 plus 1 diskutiert. Und wenn du jetzt fragst, was können wir ganz grundsätzlich sonst noch da oben tun, was sehr effektiv Dinge verändern würde. Also zum Beispiel kommen wir auf den Aspekt Klima kurz zurück, wenn du feste Emissionsovergrenzen einführst. Statt in diesem Gerede, dass sie es alle plus machen von der Klimaneutralität, was irgendwie totaler Quatsch ist und wo die Kriterien, sagen wir mal, sehr selektiv sind, was da mitgezählt wird und was nicht mitgezählt wird. Also, dass man einfach sagt, mehr als dieses dürft ihr aber nicht emittieren. Oder dass man – das ist jetzt ein bisschen weiter schon gefasst, aber ich finde das ein sehr interessantes Konzept – den Gedanken der Civil Money Councils, also dass man die Gesellschaft als Arbeitgeberin des Fußballs betrachtet, die sie ja auch faktisch ist, und nicht den Fußball als Arbeitgeber der Gesellschaft. Und dass der Fußball bei gesellschaftlichen Räten seine Mittel aushandeln muss und argumentieren muss, welche Schäden er zufügt, welche Folgen das hat und so weiter und so fort. Und natürlich würde das auch ganz massiv die Art und Weise verändern, wie der Fußball finanziert ist. Und das wiederum hat einen großen Einfluss darauf, was ich in einer Liga erlebe, also wer in der Liga oben steht. Und am Ende des Tages kommt es, glaube ich, immer auf den Punkt zurück, dass ich nicht eine Liga, eine sehr erfolgreiche Liga, ohne Milliardäre haben kann, in einer Welt, in der es Milliardäre gibt. Das ist, glaube ich, ein Punkt, den man im Hinterkopf behalten muss. Und das bedeutet nicht, dass man nicht ganz, ganz viele wahnsinnig coole Dinge mittelfristig einführen kann. Also unglaublich viele, auch oben. Noch mal ein kleines Beispiel, wenn wir über Struktur der Ligen reden. Also das ist ja auch ein sehr, sehr mächtiger Hebel. Wenn wir sagen, wir punkten Vereine nicht mehr nur für die sportliche Leistung, sondern wir punkten für das, was wirklich gesellschaftliche Leistungen sind. Also für soziales Engagement oder für Mädchenarbeit oder für Arbeit im prekären Viertel oder für ökologische Nachhaltigkeit. Und auch dann haben wir eine völlig andere Tabelle, die völlig andere Werte der Gesellschaft darstellt und die dann auch nicht mehr für dieses Rattenrennen sorgt, wo Klubs so wahnsinnig darauf angewiesen sind, dass sie sehr viel Geld für Spielerinnen bekommen, die sie sich sichern können. Weil das ist ja einer der Gründe, warum so wahnsinnig viele Gelder in den Fußball fließen. Weil um diese zentrale Ware um Spielerinnen konkurriert wird. Und wenn die nicht mehr so wichtig ist wie bisher, um Punkte zu bekommen, dann verändert das natürlich auch ganz viel. Oder zu sagen, wir belohnen Klubs jetzt dafür, was sie relativ geleistet haben. Und wir sagen zum Beispiel jemanden, der weit unten in der Tabelle steht, wenn der gegen jemanden gewinnt, der weit oben steht, dann bekommt der mehr Punkte dafür. Also das gibt es ja in diesen Schachranglisten und so weiter, dass schlechte mehr Punkte bekommen, wenn sie gegen jemanden guten gewinnen, weil das eben eine wahnsinnig große Leistung ist. Also man kann unglaublich viel verändern, wenn man auch über Strukturen spricht, über die Art und Weise, wie Wettbewerb in Anführungsstrichen ist ja – kein wirklicher Wettbewerb ist ja mehr – so ein Feudalismus eigentlich, wo man halt darauf angewiesen ist, dass man netten Gutsherren hat. Aber wenn wir es diesmal Wettbewerb nennen, da kann man also wahnsinnig viel an der Struktur verändern. Und gleichzeitig finde ich es aber auch immer wichtig, nicht aus dem Kopf zu verlieren, dass wir eben – und dann komme ich noch mal auf das zurück, wo wir eben gequatscht haben, über 50 plus 1 und so weiter – dass wir Machtverhältnisse haben, die aktuell so simplic sind, dass wir wahnsinnig große Widerstände bekommen werden, von denen, die aktuell vom System – in Anführungsstrichen – profitieren. Und das, je weniger wir systemisch machen, desto größer werden die Widerstände bleiben, weil diese Mächtigen sind ja nicht weg. Und das ist das, was man verstehen muss. Und man kann sehr, sehr viel mit dieser Zangenbewegung machen. Man kann sehr, sehr gut über ganz konkrete – wie gerade genannte – ganz viele Veränderungen sprechen. Und gleichzeitig dürfen wir aber nicht aus dem Kopf verlieren, dass die Art und Weise, wie wir gerade aktuell wirtschaften, dass es a. einfach nicht funktioniert, dass es b. das unterläuft, womit sich gerade jeder brüstet, nämlich Demokratie, die ganz massiv wieder zurückgebaut wird. Das ist ein Problem, das ganz wenige Leute begonnen haben zu verstehen. Und dass c. uns durch die Klimakatastrophe einfach die Zeit wegläuft. Und dass deshalb dieses an die Wurzeldenken auch eine Notwendigkeit ist. Das ist nicht irgendwie, dass man sagen kann, ja das ist jetzt gerade strategisch ungelegen. So kommen wir nochmal in 100 Jahren darauf zurück, wenn wir irgendwie ganz, ganz viele kleine Sachen gemacht haben. Es geht halt nicht.
Ja, da wirst du ja auch sehr deutlich in deinem Buch. Also du schreibst z.B. Der wachstumsorientierte Profisport wird diese Klimakatastrophe nicht überleben, auch wenn er sich für unsterblich hält. Er ist hoch fragil und du führst dann, das ist quasi die Argumentationsrampe, die dann zu den Obergrenzen für Emissionen unter anderem führt. Ich glaube allerdings, dass wir immer wieder an ein Thema stößen. Ich glaube, wir stößen gerade Emotionen an bei Hörerinnen und Hörern, so wie auch dein Buch bei mir auch Emotionen angestoßen hat. Und das waren – ehrlicherweise schäme ich mich ein bisschen für – aber das waren auch oft Abwehrmechanismen. Ich habe mir ganz oft gedacht, ja, wie soll denn das klappen oder wie soll denn das gehen, obwohl ich ja eigentlich auch ganz viel – also beim ganzen Problem-Teil, also wo du quasi eine – erstmal die Analyse der Gegenwart gemacht hast und so weiter – ich habe die ganze Zeit genickt. Und trotzdem war sogar ich, der ja dir dazu stimmt, war ich ganz oft so, dass du mir gedacht hast, ja, wie soll denn das jetzt gehen? Und ich habe das auch jetzt schon in diesem Gespräch erlebt. Wenn du von dem Werbeverbot im Fußball gesprochen hast, dachte ich mir, ja klar, wäre schön, aber das wird nicht klappen. Und gleichzeitig kommt noch ein zweiter Abwehrmechanismus noch mit dazu und ich glaube, den muss man sich auch eingestehen, nämlich der Gewöhnungseffekt und auch die emotionale Bindung, die wir an den Ist-Zustand haben. Es gibt natürlich wahnsinnig viel Unmut über den aktuellen Leistungssport. Gut, jetzt sind wir wieder bei den Männern, aber im Frauenfußball kann man es auch ähnlich sehen. Gleichzeitig ist es aber so, dass auch viele der kritischsten Fans, die ich kenne – und das schließt mich ein – mich stößt ganz viel am aktuellen Fußball ab. Und wenn dann aber das Champions League-Halbfinale läuft und da spielen jetzt nicht unbedingt zwei Nationalstaaten gegeneinander – die Spiele spare ich mir, aber da bin ich, glaube ich, schon radikaler als so manch anderer – dann will ich es eben doch gucken, weil das Spiel eben diese unglaubliche Faszination hat. Also das Spiel, so wie es jetzt gerade gespielt wird – und das hast du ja vorhin auch schon angesprochen – man verbindet ja auch sehr viel Positives damit. Kann das denn Hand in Hand gehen, dass wir den Fußball von der Wurzel ausgehend systemisch anders denken und trotzdem auch die Menschen mitnehmen und uns selbst ja auch ein bisschen – also ich will mich zumindest da persönlich nicht rausnehmen – die sich an diese Art des Fußballs unglaublich gewöhnt haben und sie auch lieben und vielleicht auch den Wettbewerb mögen und damit ja dann auch Formen der Gewalt, die ausübt werden in diesem System, lieben? Das gehört ja zur Wahrheit mit dazu.
Du hast ganz viele interessante Gedanken angesprochen mit den Abwehrmechanismen, das ist völlig richtig, absolut, also 100 Prozent agreed und das ist aber eigentlich glaube ich ein gutes Zeichen, weil das ist ein Zeichen dafür, dass wir wirklich anfangen, wenn wir darüber sprechen, Dinge zu verändern, weil im Prinzip jede Veränderung historisch gesehen wahnsinnige Abwehrmechanismen hervorgerufen hat. Also wenn ich nur mal das Beispiel Frauenfußball zitiere, noch in den 50er, 60er Jahren ist die Mehrheit der Gesellschaft davon ausgegangen, dass Frauen überhaupt keinen Fußball also weder spielen könnten, noch sollten, noch dürften, weil das irgendwie also medizinisch total schlecht sei und die das auch niemals könnten. Und wie oft habe ich das Argument gehört, also noch vor einigen Jahren, ja das wird ja eh niemand gucken, weil die Leute wollen das ja nicht sehen und das ist ebenso. Und das ist genau diese Argumentationsweise, dieses Fußball ist ebenso, wie wir das kennen seit eh und je und das haben wir so liebgewonnen und die Leute haben zu starke Abwehrmechanismen und das wird eben niemand gucken. Und guck dir an, was bei der letzten EM passiert ist und warum ist das passiert? Weil sich Strukturen geändert haben, weil sich Investment geändert hat, weil die Verbände das tatsächlich wollten, weil die Neigungen von Menschen – und das ist auch ganz wichtig zu verstehen – die sind nicht irgendwie in der DNA vorgeschrieben. Also bestimmt teilweise schon, aber es macht eben ganz viel auch aus, was wir zeigen, worüber wir sprechen und was auch systemisch gewollt ist. Und das ist jetzt im Frauenfußball ja nicht unbedingt eine Entwicklung, die man nur beklatschen muss, sondern es geht eben auch darum so frei nach Cola Zero, dass der Fußball rausgefunden hat, der Männer, dass er nicht mehr so wahnsinnig weit wachsen kann im Männerbereich und dass eben im Frauenbereich eine lukrative zweite Branche sein kann und so. Also es ist jetzt nicht alles sozusagen intrinsisch aus dem System heraus motiviert, aber es ist was, wenn du dir die letzten 50 Jahre anguckst, was sich wahnsinnig radikal verändert hat und was völlig unvorstellbar gewesen wäre vor 50 Jahren. Das zeigt, glaube ich, also nochmal, dass das System viel fluider ist, als wir denken, dass es ist und dass es gut ist, wenn man diese Abwehrmechanismen überhaupt erst mal anstößt. Ja, um an den Punkt zu kommen und im Prinzip alle Dinge, die wir heute als völlig selbstverständlich erleben und ich nenne jetzt auch bloß mal irgendwie Frauenwahlrecht so als einen, galten vor vor 100 Jahren als völlig radikal. Es gibt immer Abwehrmechanismen und dann ist es glaube ich wichtig, Leuten eine positive Botschaft auf den Weg mitzugeben. Also die Botschaft, es kann auch total geil sein, wenn wir Sachen, wenn wir Sachen neu machen, wenn wir Sachen verändern und das heißt ja auch überhaupt nicht, dass man den Wettbewerb abschaffen muss. Also das fände ich auch irgendwie eine absurde Reaktion. Also erstens kann man Wettbewerb ja völlig anders gestalten und das ist ja auch ein Impuls. Übrigens, das ist ja immer interessant, wenn man guckt, wie Spiele für Kinder organisiert werden. Weil die werden ja oft so organisiert, wie wir unsere Gesellschaft gerne hätten, was das Fairness beibringt und was irgendwie Toleranz beibringt und so weiter und so fort. Und bei Erwachsenen sagt man immer, ja das ist ja völlig unmöglich. Das will ja auch keiner, das geht ja nicht.
Ja, weil die haben das als Kinder nicht beigebracht bekommen, ist doch logisch.
Ja, vielleicht. Nee, aber – und Kindersport ist ja so strukturiert, also im Kindersport würde jede Trainerin irgendwie sagen, wir machen jetzt die zwei Teams ungefähr gleich stark, damit nicht das eine mit 22 zu 0 abrasiert wird. Aber dann im Erwachsenensport tut man auf einmal so, als ob das alles nicht funktionieren würde. Und diese, also ganz viele innovative Ideen, die ich in dem Buch zitiere, werden ja im Kindersport praktiziert und findet man total selbstverständlich. Und dann bei den Erwachsenen schreit man irgendwie so, Sozialismus und das geht ja nicht. Das sagt auch, glaube ich, viel über eigene Abwehrmechanismen. Und ich glaube, dass das für Leute eigentlich ja auch ein sehr selbstermächtigender Prozess sein kann, Fußball selber ein Stück weit neu zu gestalten. Also Leute beklagen sich ja wahnsinnig viel im aktuellen Fußball darüber. Wir können überhaupt nicht mitreden, wir werden überhaupt nicht gehört, wir Fans sind ja total legal und wir können ja überhaupt nicht gestalten und so weiter. Und wenn du dann an den Punkt kommst, selber diesen Prozess gestalten zu können, also nicht dem hilflos gegenüberzustehen als irgendwas, was jetzt wieder von oben irgendwie einem aufgezwungen wird, sondern selber mitgestalten zu können, dann ist das eigentlich auch was, was irgendwie sehr empowernd ist und was sehr gut Leute mitnehmen kann. Und bei manchen Aspekten wiederum muss man auch, glaube ich, dann irgendwann an den Punkt kommen, wo man sagt, es ist jetzt egal. Also das ist so ein bisschen wie Flugzeugfliegen im Zuge der Klimakatastrophe. Dass man sagen muss, ja okay, ihr habt euch vielleicht daran gewöhnt, achtmal im Jahr nach Malle zu fliegen, aber tut mir leid, das ist jetzt egal. Das können wir uns als Gesellschaft einfach nicht mehr leisten und das ist dann eben so.
Ja gut, es sind ja gar nicht die, die achtmal nach Malle fliegen. Es sind ja eher so, es ist ja eher die Luxusjacht von Roman Abramovic, das habe ich auch heute in einem Podcast gehört. Ein durchschnittlicher Mensch muss 13.700 Jahre leben, um das an CO2 zu verbrauchen, was nur diese eine Luxusjacht verbraucht.
Also natürlich dieser Kern der Probleme ist irgendwie wahnsinnig hart und deswegen hat man immer so den Impuls, sich darum herum zu bewegen und ich merke das auch. Also das ist wahnsinnig spannend, immer in diesen Diskussionen, die man zu über Fußball utopien, dass man sehr schnell immer an den Punkt kommt, so mehr oder weniger offen ausgesprochen, und ja, die Leute wollen das ja gar nicht. Also, dass man sehr stark darüber spricht, wie die Gesellschaft irgendwas rezipieren würde, aber man spricht sehr wenig eigentlich konkret über die Alternativen und man spricht sehr wenig konkret darüber, was würde daran jetzt funktionieren, was würde nicht funktionieren, wie setzen wir das um und das sorgt auch wieder ein Stück weit dafür, dass wir diesen krassen Systemismus haben, dass wir diese Hoffnungslosigkeit haben und es ist auch so ein bisschen so eine Ersatzdebatte, also man geht nicht so richtig krass in die inhaltliche Debatte, sondern es geht dann immer darum, wie würden wir denn die Gesellschaft davon überzeugen und ich glaube aber als ersten Schritt müssen wir überhaupt darüber reden, wie können wir es anders machen, bevor wir darüber reden, wie können wir die Gesellschaft davon überzeugen und was mir als letztes einfällt und das ist auch was, worüber wir am Anfang ganz kurz gesprochen haben, es sind ja bestimmte Stimmen hörbar im Fußball und andere sind eben nicht hörbar, weil sie Weil sie überhaupt nicht am Fußball teilhaben oder weil sie in einem prekären hinterletzten Winkel des Fußballs teilhaben. Und wenn wir immer sagen, die Leute möchten dies und das behalten, dann sprechen wir eben nicht über die, für die der aktuelle Fußball überhaupt gar nicht geschaffen ist und die vielleicht in einen Fußball reinströmen würden, der ganz anders funktioniert. Und das ist auch wichtig, dass man nicht die Leute als Gesellschaft verwechselt mit den Fans, die jetzt gerade in die Stadien gehen. Und ich gebe dir recht, das ist ein super schwieriger Prozess. Menschliche Abwehrkräfte sind sehr hartnäckig. Aber aus meiner Sicht gibt es überhaupt keine Alternative, als das zu versuchen. Und es ist ja auch heuchlerisch von den Leuten. Also, dass man sich wahnsinnig beschwert über all das, was irgendwie gerade läuft. Und dann sagt man, ja, aber anders wollen wir es jetzt irgendwie doch nicht so richtig.
Ja, das ist halt eine Frage der Problemdefinition. Also, ich kann mir schon vorstellen, dass es viele Menschen gibt, die jetzt per se erst mal damit zufrieden wären, wenn es in der Männerbundesliga wieder ein Meisterschaftsrennen gäbe. Und dann wären ganz viele Probleme, die du und ich anerkennen und die jetzt vielleicht auch viele Hörerinnen und Hörer ja jetzt auch quasi im Verlaufe unseres Gesprächs schon nachvollziehen konnten. Die wären zwar noch da, aber ich kann mir eben schon vorstellen, dass der Gewöhnungsmechanismus so stark ist, dass du dann sagst, nee, das ist eigentlich für mich okay. Ich will ja einfach nur – also das ist ja interessant, wenn man sich anguckt, wer waren bisher so die radikalsten Stimmen im Fußball, dann waren das ganz oft Menschen, die sich den Fußball der 80er zurück gewünscht haben, die Männerfußball der 80er.
Ja, absolut, absolut. Und das bringt mich nach zwei Punkten, die mir gerade einfallen. Also erstens, was ich super wichtig finde, ist, wir müssen aufhören, über Zeit zu diskutieren, bitte. Immer im Fußball. Ja, wirklich. Der Fußball der 70er, der Fußball vor den 90ern. Ja, und natürlich der Fußball, wie er damals war, hat geradezu zwangsläufig dahin geführt, wie er heute ist. Und das sieht man ja am Fußball der Frauen, der sich jetzt genau auf dieselbe Art und Weise entwickelt. Und es ist totaler Quatsch, über Zeit zu reden, sondern man muss anfangen, über Systeme zu reden und nicht über Zeit. Und das ist, glaube ich, was eine Argumentationsweise, die sehr stark aus dem Kapitalismus kommt, wie wir ihn gerade haben, was uns auch gar nicht so sehr bewusst ist, dass wir sehr, sehr viel abhängig machen vom Geschmack der Leute. Also, dass wir bei sehr, sehr vielen Dingen sagen, ja, aber wenn die Leute das okay finden, dann ist es ja auch legitim. Sozusagen die verlängerte Form von der Kunde kauft ja.
Als hätte man darüber abgestimmt.
Als hätte man darüber, ja, genau. Und bei vielen Dingen ist es ja aber einfach so, dass Probleme existieren, die aber Menschen, also wahlweise nicht so richtig bewusst sind, wahlweise relativ egal sind, wahlweise – ach, ich weiß auch nicht – sie das vielleicht sogar ganz gut finden. Aber das ist nicht das einzige Argument dafür, eine Welt so zu haben, wie sie ist, weil eben also die ganzen Schäden, die dadurch entstehen – und das muss man nochmal so klar sagen – die tragen wir als Gesellschaft. Also die Gewinne im Fußball werden privatisiert und die Kosten davon, sowohl die Kosten als auch die Schäden, die tragen wir. Und die Sponsoren, die da Geld reingeben und die Fernseher anstalten, das sind nicht irgendwelche Gelder, die da irgendjemand aus seinem Portemonnaie rausgezogen hat, sondern das sind unsere Mittel als Gesellschaft, die dadurch reinfließen, dass sei es Konzerne wie VW teilweise dem Staat gehören, wo sozusagen dann ganz direkt irgendwie – oder wenn, sagen wir mal, eine Kommune irgendwie einen Club rettet, wo ganz direkt unsere Steuergelder reinfließen – sei es, dass Konzerne wie Bayer zum Nulltarif die Biodiversität zerstören und Gifte exportieren, die überhaupt nicht erlaubt sind mehr in der EU, und dann die Gelder, die sie daraus ziehen, wiederum in den Fußball investieren. Und das heißt, der Fußball profitiert von unseren gesamtgesellschaftlichen Mitteln, in dem Fall der Natur, von der wir alle leben, die zerstört werden. Oder sei es die Sportwetten, die wir kaufen und unsere Gelder werden daran investiert, dass sie in Gelder einzelner Profis fließen, während die Leute halt da sitzen und all ihr Hab und Gut verlieren, weil sie süchtig nach Sportwetten sind, all das. Und das sind ganz, ganz viele Schäden, die die Menschen nicht bewusst sind. Aber es ist nicht die einzige Legitimation zu sagen, ja, das stört halt nicht genug Leute, und dann belassen wir es halt dabei. Also die Sklaverei hat auch eine ganze lange Zeit lang nicht genug Leute gestört, und das macht sie trotzdem nicht legitim. Und das ist was, was man auch verstehen muss in dieser Debatte. Also wir sind halt vom Kapitalismus irgendwie so geprägt, dass man sagt, ja, wenn genug Leute das konsumieren, dann ist es schon okay. Nein, ist es nicht.
Ich vermute mal, viele von euch haben so wie ich bei der Aufnahme genickt, als Alina diesen letzten Punkt gemacht hat. Nur weil etwas nicht genügend Leute stört, ist es nicht in Ordnung. Ich bin der Überzeugung, dass sie damit vollkommen Recht hat. Erst viele Wochen nach unserem Gespräch bei der Arbeit an dieser Sendung ist mir aber aufgefallen, wie heikel diese Feststellung eigentlich ist. Denn wer den Fußball demokratisch reformieren will, der braucht eben doch eine Grundmasse an Menschen, die sich an Problemen stört – und das sollte eine große Zahl an Menschen sein. Ich denke, niemand von uns will, dass eine progressive Minderheit der Mehrheit etwas überstirbt. Noch dazu, weil die Gefahr dann sehr groß wäre, dass eben doch wieder diejenigen keine Möglichkeit haben, an der Veränderung teilzunehmen, die schon jetzt vom Fußball ausgeschlossen werden. Ein gemeinsames Bewusstsein für die gesellschaftliche Ausbeutung durch den Fußball müsste eigentlich die Grundlage für alle Veränderungen sein. Doch dieses Bewusstsein herzustellen, ist schwierig. Unter anderem weil diejenigen, die im Fußball die Macht haben, das mit aller Kraft verhindern wollen – und diejenigen, die über den Fußball berichten, von seiner aktuellen Form abhängig sind. Noch dazu bewegen wir uns in einer Welt, in der selbst Fakten oft nicht akzeptiert werden. Manchmal hat man das Gefühl, es sei unmöglich, sich überhaupt noch auf irgendetwas zu einigen. Und dann das Ganze ausgerechnet in dem Bereich zu tun, den viele zur Entspannung nutzen, um einfach mal emotional sein zu dürfen? Da liegt noch ne Menge Arbeit vor uns. Außerdem stellt sich die Frage, welche Akteure können denn überhaupt eine Veränderung anstoßen, wenn so viele im System Fußball keinerlei Interesse daran haben?
Im Prinzip kann jeder was vorantreiben, denn nicht ganz konkret, sagen wir mal, in den obersten drei Ligen, wäre jetzt so mein Gefühl, im Fußball involviert ist. Also vielleicht die auch, aber ich würde immer sagen, das ist so ähnlich wie bei der katholischen Kirche oder sonstigen sehr resistenten Organen. Wande kommt eben von der Basis oder von staatlicher Seite oder in jedem Fall von außen, aber er wird nicht aus diesen Strukturen heraus entstehen.
Also auch nicht von den Ultras zum Beispiel oder meinst du jetzt Mitarbeitende?
Ich meine tatsächlich Mitarbeitende, ich meine tatsächlich Aktive und auch da muss man noch mal so ein bisschen differenzieren, weil ich glaube zum Beispiel, dass SpielerInnen auch ein total guter Hebel sein können, der noch überhaupt nicht entdeckt worden ist. Also mit denen spricht ja kein Mensch im Prinzip. Wenn wir diese Diskussion führen, dann werden ja immer so Fan-Diskussionen geführt und so weiter. Und es gibt aber überhaupt keine erstmal Bildung von SpielerInnen, um bewusst zu machen, in welchem System sie sich gerade bewegen, aber auch um ihren Input, ihre Erfahrungen zu bekommen für diese Diskussion. Und dann ist es ja eigentlich ein wahnsinnig wirkungsmächtiges Element, weil diese Leute auf dem Platz stehen. Und wenn diese Leute sich entscheiden, nicht zu spielen, dann findet kein Fußballspiel statt. So einfach ist das. Also das ist im Prinzip diese alte Rede davon, alle Räder stehen still, wenn der starke Arm es will. Das ist ja im Fußball tatsächlich noch so. Also wenn die 22 nicht spielen, dann spielt eben niemand. Das ist eine wahnsinnig große Gruppe, die überhaupt noch nicht richtig entdeckt ist, sage ich mal in Anführungsstrichen, die aber ja im Fußball eine ganz relevante, teilnehmende, aktive Gruppe sind. Ich glaube auch, dass ganz viele Trainerinnen von weiter unten, sage ich mal, wo der Druck nicht so stark ist, was tun können. Also das fragen mich auch Leute, so was kann ich ganz konkret als Trainerin machen, wie kann ich mich positionieren in diesem System. Das sind ja Fragen, die Menschen umtreiben. Ich glaube, dass definitiv von außen von der Gesellschaft, in Anführungsstrichen, mehr Druck kommen muss. Also das können Fans sein. Ultras sind vielleicht nicht immer der geeignete Träger für solche Proteste. Also sie sind natürlich wahnsinnig gut organisiert, aber es ist auch das Problem, dass es sehr, sehr oft eben um tagesaktuelle Themen geht. Also dann geht es halt irgendwie um Pyro-Debatten oder um so ganz greifbare tagesaktuelle Dinge. Und die sind natürlich auch sehr, sehr stark geprägt von diesem Fußball, wie er jetzt aktuell ist. Und ich finde das immer so interessant, wenn ich mit Leuten spreche, so aus dem Sportjournalismus oder so, die irgendwie vielleicht ein bisschen quer eingestiegen sind. Ich merke übrigens auch, das ist auch noch so ein interessanter Gedanke am Rande, dass ich von Männern sehr, sehr viel mehr Widerspruch kriege als von Frauen, wenn ich so Ideen ausbreite. Also, weil ich glaube, dass die das nicht so stark so als ihr System begreifen, weil sie vielleicht auch das Gefühl haben, nicht so richtig gewollt zu sein in dieser Welt und die dann eher so sagen, ja klar, machen wir anders, kein Problem. Und das heißt, ich glaube, es ist ganz wichtig, dass Leute agieren, die nicht so ganz stark im Fußball verflochten sind, also die das System kennen. Das ist sicherlich sehr stark von Vorteil, aber die so ein bisschen quer reingestiegen sind, die nicht seit sie vier sind irgendwie Fußball spielen. Dann der Start, so wie er aktuell ist. Also es ist auch ein sehr unterdrückender Mechanismus, aber ist natürlich auch ein Akteur, der einiges machen kann, also der dem Fußball eben ganz konkrete Vorschriften machen kann. Oder wenn wir es mal weiterfassen, die Politik so in der Breite gefasst. Also das sind ja alles Akteure, die von außen kommen. Auch progressive Unternehmen, auch progressive Unternehmen können Forderungen reinstellen und haben das ja auch durchaus getan in dieser DFL Task Force. Also wenn man dem glauben kann, was da rausgesickert ist, dann waren es ja auch unter anderem Unternehmen, die gesagt haben, ihr könnt jetzt nicht immer so weitermachen, wie ihr das gerade getan habt. Da geht es dann natürlich nicht um Wettbewerb, sondern irgendwie um Klima und so weiter. Und ich finde das auch ganz interessant, dass es Clubbesitzer gibt, die natürlich ganz furchtbar sind systemisch, aber die dann sagen, wie in Italien, wo sich letztens so ein Investor geäußert hat und gesagt hat, ja, wir können nicht weiter so ungleich verteilen, weil dann wird sich irgendwann eine Super League gründen. Das ist ja auch total spannend. Also im Grunde können von ganz vielen Seiten Impulse reinkommen und Bewegung reinkommen. Als allerletztes von den Verantwortungstragenden im Fußball, das wird einfach nicht passieren. Also ich rede jetzt vom Spitzenfußball, von wie gesagt den ersten zwei, drei Ligen. Das wird nicht passieren. Auch deswegen, weil die Leute unter so wahnsinnigem Druck stehen, zu funktionieren. Weil so wahnsinnig viel in ihrem Alltag passiert und sie überhaupt nicht die Zeit haben, einen Schritt zurückzugehen und zu sagen, hey in welchem System stecke ich da eigentlich drin und wem diene ich da eigentlich. Aber im Grunde alle anderen genannten TrägerInnen können wahnsinnig viel tun. Und ganz, ganz wichtig finde ich auch, dass es mehr Verbindungen gibt zwischen denen, die im Fußball was verändern möchten und zwischen den Protestgruppen, NGOs, politischen Bewegungen, die gesellschaftlich was verändern wollen. Weil im Prinzip sprechen wir alle über dieselben Themen, aber es gibt kaum Verbindungen. Man holt den jeweils anderen nicht ins Boot und im Grunde, was du ja brauchst, ist eine ganz mächtige gesellschaftliche Druckwelle und die kannst du aber nicht erreichen, wenn du im Fußball irgendwie vor dich hinwurschtest und man so tut, als hätte das mit dem Rest der Gesellschaft überhaupt nichts zu tun. Das heißt, politische Allianzen sind auch total wichtig. A long story short, das sind ganz, ganz viele verschiedene Gruppen, die jeweils ihren Teil beitragen können. Sicherlich nicht jede Gruppe jeden Teil, weil eben auch einzelne Interessen dahinter stehen. Aber man kann schon sehr gut Allianzen bilden, um den Fußball zur Bewegung zu zwingen und das ist auch ziemlich notwendig.
Die Football-Fans for Future oder Football-Supporters. Abschließende Frage, Alina, und bei dir bin ich sehr gespannt auf die Antwort. Wie sieht der Fußball in zehn Jahren aus?
Ja, das ist eine sehr interessante Frage. Die wird tatsächlich oft gestellt, aber ich befürchte tatsächlich, also wenn wir jetzt vom Ist-Zustand ausgehen und wir sagen, es gibt keine Bewegung, die plötzlich auftaucht und wir sagen irgendwie alles, was im Gefolge vielleicht dieses Buches oder irgendeiner Debatte passieren könnte, wird nicht passieren, sondern einfach sagen wir mal, so wie der Fußball gerade ist, wird es weitergehen, dann denke ich, dass der FC Bayern Deutscher Meister sein wird, bei den Männern und bei den Frauen, dass Großclubs noch mächtiger sein werden, dass wir möglicherweise ein System haben, was ein bisschen angelehnt ist ans US-Amerikanische, also dass es Clubbesitzer gibt, vielleicht nicht unbedingt in Deutschland, bin ich unsicher, weil er doch 50-1 und Heiliger Graal ist, aber noch sehr viel stärker unterwandert, als es aktuell so ist, mit der Tendenz, geschlossene Ligen zu gründen, weil man keine andere Möglichkeit zulassen will, den Fußball gleicher zu machen. Also man wird nicht zulassen wollen, Gelder direkt umzuverteilen, sondern dann geht man eben auf die kleine Insel und teilt sich das Spanzerke, um mal im Bild der geschlossenen Liga zu bleiben und ich glaube, wo es sich am massivsten verändern wird, ist in Bezug auf Emissionen und so weiter, weil es einfach so sein muss, weil die ganze Dynamik, die wir aktuell erleben, die ja eine ziemlich gruselige Dynamik ist, wenn man sich so diesen Sommer anguckt und offensichtlich hat es ja noch nicht mal so richtig begonnen, was da alles kommen wird, das wird sehr stark an Tempo zunehmen und das wird bedeuten, dass es sicherlich Emissions-Obergrenzen geben wird, dass der Fußball sich umstellen muss in Bezug auf seine Wachstumslogik, das glaube ich auch und das möglicherweise auch in Bezug auf die ganzen gesellschaftlichen Krisen, die wir jetzt gerade erleben und was ja alles auch im Zuge dessen kommt, wie wir wirtschaften, also Inflation, Kriege, verschiedenste Krisen, Es gibt so viele große Krisen, Energiekrisen und so weiter, dass der Fußball einfach an Bedeutung verliert, weil die Menschen so multiple Krisen erleben in ihrem Leben, dass sie sich einfach erstens vielleicht nicht mehr drei Abos leisten können oder möchten, vielleicht nicht mehr die Dauerkarte leisten können oder möchten. Und das heißt, dass der Fußball eine gewisse Schrumpfung durchleben könnte, weil einfach durch diese extreme Umbruchssituation, die wir erleben werden, andere Dinge in den Vordergrund treten. Und es wäre nicht unbedingt das schönste Szenario für den Fußball, weil es wäre ja gut, wenn wir statt auf diesem Fußball des 19. Jahrhunderts zu beharren und damit unterzugehen, ein Fußball des 21. Jahrhunderts schaffen, der die Menschen weiter begleiten kann. Also von daher ist diese Abwanderungsthese gar nicht so mein liebster Ausgang. Das wäre mir wichtig, dass wir das schaffen. Und das ist jetzt vielleicht die ausführlichere Version der Antwort. Sonst sage ich einfach immer, der FC Bayern wird Meister. Bei Männern und Frauen Punkt. Aber das ist die ausführlichere Antwort.
Alina, du hast sehr viele ausführliche Antworten gegeben. Es hat mir großen Spaß mit dir gemacht. Ich hätte noch locker drei Stunden mit dir weiterreden können. Vielleicht machen wir das mal an anderer Stelle. Danke dir für deine Zeit.
Ja, vielen, vielen lieben Dank auch dir. Es war voll interessant und es waren gute Fragen.
Tja, was fangen wir mit all dem jetzt an? Meine Gedanken dazu sind die folgenden. Erstens, die Probleme des Fußballs sind in seinem Wirtschaftssystem begründet. Spätestens ab dem Zeitpunkt, in dem er zur Unterhaltungsindustrie wurde, war wirtschaftliches Wachstum nicht nur Nebeneffekt, sondern existenzielle Grundlage. Ob aus Gier, falschem Optimismus oder vor dem Hintergrund, dass wirtschaftlicher und sportlicher Erfolg untrennbar miteinander verbunden sind, ist eigentlich egal. Fest steht, im Leistungssegment ist Fußball immer auf Wachstum hin ausgerichtet. Sobald die Entwicklung stagniert, wie zum Beispiel rund um den Männer-Bundesliga-Skandal 1971 oder nach der Kirchinsolvenz 2002, stehen die ersten Clubs vor dem wirtschaftlichen Bankrott. Alles ist auf dieses Wachstum hin ausgerichtet, und vieles im Fußball lässt sich damit erklären, auch die Konzentration von Geld und Macht bei einigen wenigen Vereinen. Deshalb würde es uns auch nicht weiterbringen, den Fußball der 80er oder 90er zu reproduzieren. Überspitzt gesagt, lasst uns alle Vereine auf Null zurücksetzen und die Bundesliga neu gründen, in 50 Jahren hätten wir dieselben Probleme, nur vielleicht mit anderen Namen. Gleichzeitig wirkt diese Fixierung auf Wachstum von den Top-Clubs an der Bundesliga-Spitze bis hinein in den Breitensport beim Dorfverein. Nicht nur weil der Breitensport reproduziert, was im Leistungssport passiert, schaut euch nur die FC Bayern und Hoffenheim-Klonen in der Provinz an, die es dort immer wieder gibt, sondern allein deshalb, weil der Fußball mit seinem vertikalen Liegensystem auf Verdrängung hin konzipiert ist und nicht darauf, hier ein Spiel zu spielen. Das schließt Menschen aus und führt bis in die untersten Ligen hinein zur Ungleichheit, die wir zwar alle akzeptieren, die im Fußball aber eigentlich nie angelegt war. Wer auf dem Bolzplatz oder im Park in einer Gruppe spielt, achtet bei der Zusammenstellung auf ungefähre Chancengleichheit. Warum wirkt der Gedanke eigentlich so absurd, das auch im Breitensport zu machen? Vermutlich auch deshalb, weil sich im Fußball etwas abbildet, das Deutschland sehr geprägt hat – das Leistungsprinzip. Wer seine Leistung bringt, hat jeden Erfolg verdient. Wie umfassend diese Denke unsere Gesellschaft prägt, hat etwas gezeigt, das im März 2003, also vor 20 Jahren, passiert ist.
Wir werden, meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren, Leistungen des Staates kürzen, Eigenverantwortung fordern und mehr Eigenleistung von jedem Einzelnen abfordern müssen. Alle Kräfte der Gesellschaft werden ihren Beitrag leisten müssen, Unternehmer und Arbeitnehmer, Freiberuflich Tätige und auch Rentner.
Das war der damalige Kanzler Gerhard Schröder in seiner Regierungserklärung zur Agenda 2010, mit der, so Schröder, der Sozialstaat umgebaut, nicht abgebaut werden sollte. Der Kündigungsschutz wurde gelockert, Arbeitslosen und Sozialhilfe zusammengelegt, Fördern durchfordern war das Mantra hinter den meisten Maßnahmen. Klingt ja auch erstmal logisch. Wer viel leistet, soll dafür belohnt werden. Und wer zu bequem dafür ist, dem steht eben nicht zu viel zu. Aber ein Mehr an Leistung schien damals unbedingt notwendig. Als Schröder 2003 seine Agenda auch gegen parteiinternen Widerstand durchsetzt, bankt man in Deutschland um die wirtschaftliche Entwicklung. Nach den Platzen der New Economy Blase stagniert das Wachstum, weit über vier Millionen Menschen sind arbeitslos. Allerdings war dieses Prinzip zu einfach für eine Welt, die in sich bereits ungleich strukturiert ist, in der Minderheiten und Schwache bereits ohne eine Verschärfung ihrer Situation benachteiligt waren. Die Ungleichheit in Deutschland ist in den letzten 20 Jahren rapide gewachsen, genauso wie der Niedriglohnsektor. Als die Regierungserklärung von Gerhard Schröder neulich 20. Geburtstag hatte, konnte man viel Kritik an seiner Agenda lesen. Na ja, außer auf Seiten von industrienahen Publikationen, da wurde von einer, ich zitiere, beispiellosen Erfolgsgeschichte berichtet. Merkregel, wenn die Meinungen so auseinandergehen, haben wohl doch nicht.
Alle Kräfte der Gesellschaft ihren Beitrag leisten müssen.
Was all das mit Fußball zu tun hat? Ich glaube, wer in seinem Alltag erlebt, dass gleiche Leistung eben nicht zu gleichem Erfolg führt, wird für Ungerechtigkeiten sensibilisiert. Sicher kommt es auch daher, dass manche von uns auf den Fußball blicken, dieselben Probleme erkennen und das so nicht mehr hinnehmen wollen. Wer mit dem Leistungsprinzip und dem Wirtschaftssystem nicht zufrieden ist, hat aber ein Problem. Auch die Strukturen des Fußballs sind darauf ausgerichtet, und zwar von der DFL bis hin zu den Landesverbänden im Breitensport. Innerhalb solcher Strukturen, die alle abhängig vom aktuellen System sind, ist wenig Veränderung möglich. Gleichzeitig werden uns die aktuellen Vorschläge nicht helfen, weil sie nur die Symptome nicht aber den Grund für die Probleme bekämpfen. Wenn wir gleichzeitig auf eine Wand zurasen, die jeder sieht, die die wenigsten aber zum Anlass für eine Vollbremsung nehmen wollen, die drohende Selbstauslöschung der Spezies Mensch oder wie es euphemistisch heißt die Klimakatastrophe. Zu krass formuliert? Wenn man den aktuellen Weltklimabericht des IPCC liest, nicht wirklich. Der bezeichnet sich selbst als Überlebensleitfaden für die Menschheit. Aber wer hat schon Lust, sich gedanklich auf eine so düstere Gegenwartsanalyse einzulassen? Ich ja auch nicht, hab den nur überflogen. Weil es so deprimierend ist und weil es einen auch schnell überfordert. Da ist es viel einfacher, sich mit dem Videobeweis oder dem überraschenden 2 zu 1 am Wochenende zu beschäftigen. Der Fußball war immer schon eine wunderschöne Flucht vor dem Alltag. Kann das nicht einfach so bleiben? Vermutlich ist es eine Frage der Perspektive. Es kann schön sein, in der von einem Würstchen-Hersteller aufgestellten Fanbox lustige Liedchen zu singen. Man kann aber auch fragen, wie der Verein, zu dem die Würstchen-Fanbox gehört, zwischenzeitlich über 200 Millionen Euro Schulden anhäufen konnte und das, obwohl seine Fans so bekloppt sind, dass sie immer hinter ihm stehen. Oder geht vielleicht beides? Sich am Spieltag ganz und gar in den Fußball werfen, ihn davor und danach aber systemisch zu hinterfragen? Denn das ist ja leider auch wahr. Wenn man Probleme mit dem aktuellen Fußball hat und zu ihnen schweigt, dann wird sich der Fußball nur noch weiter von einem weg entwickeln. Ohne Widerstand verändert sich gar nichts. Die bestehenden Verhältnisse durften lediglich extremer werden. Aber wo anfangen mit dem Wunsch, den Fußball zu verändern? Erst im eigenen und dann in fremden Köpfen. Ich glaube, wir müssen anders über den Fußball sprechen und denken. Wir müssen so ehrlich sein, die Wurzeln seiner Probleme anzusprechen, selbst wenn man damit bei so sechs Themen wie Kapitalismus landet. Wir müssen uns dazu zwingen, anders über Fußball zu denken, vom Spiel auszugehen und nicht vom Wettbewerb. Wir müssen über Ideen sprechen, die utopisch sind und vielleicht sogar weltfremd erscheinen, weil wir sie damit normalisieren und unser Denken aus den aktuellen Strukturen befreien. Für eine Diskussion über die Zukunft des Fußballs kann ein Tribünengespräch wie dieses nur der Anfang gewesen sein. Wenn wir Glück haben, hören wir das hier in einigen Jahren und schütteln die Köpfe, für welche banalen Feststellungen der Max im Jahr 2023 so viel Zeit gebraucht hat. Es wäre ein gutes Zeichen. Weil es das Spiel Fußball wert ist. Vom Kick auf der Wiese bis zum Finale im großen Stadion. Und weil im Fußball eine einzigartige Chance liegt. Die kommenden Jahre werden fordernd sein, sicher auch überfordernd. Unser Leben wird sich voraussichtlich so krass verändern, wie es vorher nur Generationen gegangen ist, die Krieg erlebt haben. Und wer weiß, ob nicht sogar wir Krieg noch näher zu spüren bekommen. Der Lebensraum von weit über 3 Milliarden Menschen ist laut Weltklimabericht besonders von der Klimakatastrophe betroffen. Große Landstriche werden kein Lebensraum mehr für den Menschen sein. Kaum vorstellbar, dass sie daraus entstehenden Konflikte alle friedlich gelöst werden können. Das kann einem Angst machen. Sollte es wahrscheinlich auch. Es sollte uns aber nicht lähmen, sondern aktivieren. Noch können wir einschreiten. Vielleicht kann der Fußball für uns nicht nur Eskapismus sein, sondern uns dabei helfen, die Angst vor der Zukunft abzubauen, indem wir ihn verändern und an die neuen Realitäten anpassen. Dabei das Spiel neu entdecken und sehen, es ist anders, aber genauso schön. Lasst uns diesen für uns so wichtigen Teil unserer Welt neu denken. In der Hoffnung, dass wir es noch rechtzeitig schaffen und damit nicht nur die Zukunft des Fußballs neu gestalten. Das war Tribünengespräch Nummer 51. Geschrieben, gesprochen und produziert von mir Max Jakob Ost. Vielen Dank an meine Gäste Alina Schwärmer, Christian Spiller und Raphael Molter. Alle Informationen zu Ihren Büchern sind in den Show Notes zu finden. Sprecherin der Einspieler war Julia Meyer. Auf jm-mediumproduktion.de könnt ihr sie vor eurer eigenen Projekte buchen. Ich möchte sie euch sehr empfehlen. Julia rockt. Ihr habt sie gehört. Jetzt aber bin ich unheimlich gespannt auf euer Feedback. Unter mitmachen.rasenfunk.de könnt ihr uns schreiben. Und bitte unterstützt den Rasenfunk finanziell. Allein diese Folge hat rund 700 Euro gekostet. Und logischerweise ist meine Arbeitszeit da gar nicht mit drin. Das wollen wir glaube ich alle nicht wissen. Wie ihr uns Geld überweisen könnt, erfahrt ihr auf rasenfunk.de slash supporters club. Es würde uns auch helfen, wenn ihr diese Folge weiterempfehlt und uns eine Bewertung auf den einschlägigen Podcast-Plattformen gebt. Und zu guter Letzt haben wir noch Merch, den wir unter kiosk.rasenfunk.de verkaufen. Auch damit könnt ihr uns supporten. Und hey, ihr seht dabei sogar noch gut aus. Danke für eure Aufmerksamkeit, bleibt im Rasenfunk gewogen, bleibt gesund und dann hören wir uns schon bald wieder. Macht's gut!
Das war das Rasenfunk – Tribünengespräch. Wir gehen nun zurück in die angeschlossenen Funkhäuser.